ALAN ARCHULETA ADKINS BAIT-
FORGES BRADFORD CABRERO QUARTET
THE DALLY DIED TORONTO THANKS
MAN GLAZER GONZALES GROVE
HERZBERG WAY SO- TADO JONES CAN
LONGER LAYERED LEYVA THE MON
REQUIRE MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TELEPHOTO HAN PERSON
TINO ROTH. IBM SKINNER STERN
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE STEVE WEINER
WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUEST B. ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY SENATOR ACHEN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AS WE START OUR DAY
IN THIS SESSION. LET ME ASK US
ESPECIALLY TO KEEP SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON HIS FATHER AND
THE ENTIRE FAMILY IN OUR
THOUGHTS AND OUR HEARTS. AS
THEY BEAR THE LOSS OF HIS
MOTHER VERY EARLY THIS MORNING.
CREATOR GOD. AS I WEAR MY MASK
TODAY HELP ME APPRECIATE THE
BLESSING AND THE PROTECTION OF
THIS CLOTH. LET IT BE AN
OUTWARD SIGN OF AN INWARD
GRACE. A TANGIBLE AND VISIBLE
WAY OF LIVING LOVE FOR MY
NEIGHBORS AS I LOVE MYSELF.
SINCE MY LIPS WILL BE COVERED
AND COVER MY HEART THAT PEOPLE
MAY SEE MY SMILE IN THE
PREQUELS AROUND MY EYES. SINCE
MY VOICE MAY BE MUFFLED HELP ME
TO SPEAK CLEARLY NOT ONLY WITH
MY WORDS BUT WITH MY ACTIONS.
AS THE ELASTIC TOUCHES MY EARS
REMIND ME TO LISTEN CAREFULLY
AND FULL OF CARE TO ALL THOSE
THAT MEET. ME THIS SIMPLE PIECE
OF CLOTH B. SHIELD AND BANNER
AND MAKE EACH BREATH THAT IT
HOLDS BE FILLED WITH YOUR LOVE
I'M IN. CENTERS FOR YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART. AS YOU
REMEMBER OUR FALLEN. MEN AND
WOMEN WHO SERVE OUR GREAT
COUNTRY. AND ESPECIALLY TODAY
TO THE GOLD STAR MOTHERS WHO
LOST THEIR CHILD. IN SERVICE OF
OUR COUNTRY FOLLOW ME PLEASE I
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT PRAYER AND-
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
MEMBERS OF MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED TO READ
MESSAGES MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED DREAD
REPORTS A COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED DREAD AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOVING ONTO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN D. N. TWENTY
NINE OR TWENTY NINE POINT
SEVENTY- THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT S. B. THREE THREE ZERO
AND ITEM FORTY SIX S. B. FOUR
NINETY FOUR. THERE ARE FOUR
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK THEY
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO OTHER MOTIONS SENATOR
LAYERED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- PLEASE PULL FILE
ITEM THREE THREE FIVE A. B.
EIGHT NINE EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. SO ORDERED. SENATOR
EYES OF THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW SENATE BILL
TWO SEVENTY BERMAN GROSSING AND
ROLLING AND RETURN THE MEASURE
TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER
ACTION. IF THERE IS NO
OBJECTION SO ORDERED SAYING NO
OBJECTION SENATOR CHI LETTER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RECALL SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
TWO FROM THE GOVERNOR'S DESK IN
RETURN THE MEASURE TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION. IF
THERE IS NO OBJECTION IT IS SO
ORDERED THING NO OBJECTION. ANY
FURTHER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS OR
NOTICES. SAYING NINE MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SUCH A SECOND READING FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1-035-101-5840.
452-752-6403 SIX FORTY TWO
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED TO READ.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT ITEMS NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE SENATOR BATES. BUT ADDS A
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF KENNETH
BERMAN. THESE APPOINTEES WERE
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST TWENTY
FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BUILT. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE- WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE- THE LIST ONCE AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA PUT THE BILLS ON
CALL UNTIL WE GET A FULL HOUSE
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
I MEAN I PLEASE- CHOLERA. ALAN
ARCHULETA. HI ADKINS FIVE BASE
FIVE BACKER FIVE FORTUS I
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM. HI
CORTESE I DALLY. I DONT FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN. I BLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. FIVE KURTZ
BURKE FIVE WEST SO. HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER. WHERE I
LABOR I THE MON. MAGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN.
NIELSEN BUT HELLO FOLKS I CAN I
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO
I SKINNER. STERN NUMBER ALL
RIGHT I LIKE CASTING I WINNER.
WILKE HI. SENATOR BATES BATES
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX SENATOR BATES.
I HAVE MY OWN NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN YOU DID SAY THAT SKEWS ME
I THOUGHT I HEARD TWENTY SIX
FIVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN.
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF FALLING
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
APPOINTMENTS NIKOLAEV ABBY'S
RAJI BRIAR AND SEAN YANG TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY REGIONAL BOARD
BEATRICE GONZALEZ TO THE
COLORADO RIVER BASIN BOARD AND
ROBERT D. OFF TO THE HOUSE
LAHONTAN BOARD. THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
TWENTY FIFTH ON FIVE OUT OF
FIVE ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THESE ITEMS. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA. HI
ATKINS. I BASE. I BACKER. I
FORGES. HI BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM ARE YOU PROTECTING. HI
DOLLY. HI TODD HI DURAZO BY
ADMIN I GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HER TADO. JONES I CAN
LONGER. LAYERED I LLEVA I THE
MON. MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. FIVE
MEN I NEWMAN. NIELSEN CONTROL
OF BOTH. PAN ARCADE FORTUNE
TINO. I. ROSS. I RUBIO I
SKINNER FIVE STERNE IM BERG HI
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER.
WELL I SENATORS SENATOR BATES
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WERE READY
TO MOVE ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE'RE GONNA START WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO. THIRTY
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR AND
THIRTY FIVE- CALL ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY- YOUR SENATOR MCGUIRE.
HI MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE FIGURES THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND PRESENT THE MORNING
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING MADAM
PRESIDENT- IT CAME VERY QUICKLY
AND THEN THE SECOND TO BE
SIMPLY ADDED A BASELINE
DEFINITION FOR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS HERE IN SD SEVENTY ONE
THAT DISTILLS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. AN ITEM. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS I BASE. HI BACKER HI
FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE A- HI
PROTESTING HI DALLY I DON HI
TORONTO. I EGGMAN I GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROW. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HER TADO. JONES I CAN
LONGER. HI FLARED I LLEVA I THE
MON. MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN.
I NEWMAN. NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO. I.
ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG I Y. CASTING I WINNER. I
WILL. HI SENATOR MCGUIRE MOVES
THE CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY TWO. SENATOR
GONZALES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- EXCUSE
ME- MADAM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ MY APOLOGIES SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CENTER GONZALEZ THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO
SP THREE SEVENTY CLARIFIED
DEFINITIONS PERTAINING TO LOCAL
AGENCIES AND FIBER OPTIC OPTIC
WIRES FOR THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT I WILL
BE SUBMITTING A LETTER TO THE
SENATE JOURNAL TO FURTHER
CLARIFY THE INTENT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT RESPECTIVELY ASK
FOR NIGHT BOAT. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE THING MAN. THIS IS. UP
ACTUALLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BASE I BACKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A ARE YOU
PROTESTING HI DALLY I DON. I
THE ROSIN I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
ARE YOU CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROSS.
I HEARD SPURRED BY WAY SO HI
HER TADO. JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON. I
REQUIRE. MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN I
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN HI A TRIO OF
BOTH. I PAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA
HI RALPH. FIVE RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOUSE E. I. WINNER HI WELL HI
CENTER GOOD SOLID SMOOTHS THE
CALL. ON TO ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR SENATOR ROB.
HE IS PREPARED PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR RALPH IN ACTION
RELATING TO PEOPLE HEALTH
CENTER ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
BILL EMPOWERS PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS TO BE BETTER
ADVOCATES FOR THEIR STUDENTS
HEALTH BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP TYPE ONE
DIABETES INFORMATIONAL
MATERIALS. AND BY REQUIRING
SCHOOLS TO DISTRIBUTE THIS
INFORMATION TO FAMILIES
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY CLARIFY WHEN THE
MATERIALS ARE PROVIDED TO
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS AND REMOVE
A REQUIREMENT FOR CDC TO
CONSULT WITH THE GOVERNING
BOARDS OF SCHOOLS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND INSTEAD AUTHORIZE
CD TO COORDINATE WITH ANY OTHER
ENTITY IT DEEMS APPROPRIATE.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
ON A VERY VERY SERIOUS ISSUE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
RIVALS. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE BASE
I BACKER. I PORCHES HI BRADFORD
I HAVE ITEM HI CORTEZ E. I.
DALLY I DODD. FIVE TORONTO I
EXAMINED EYE LASER ARKANSAS AS
I GROW. HIHURTS BURKE I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO. JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED I LLEVA FIVE THE MOON
I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S. FIVE
MEN I NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM HI FOURTEEN
TINA. HI RALPH. I RUBIO I CAN-
I STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI SENATOR ROTH
MUSICAL MOVING ON TO ITEM FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE SENATOR
DODD IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ONE OH NINE BY SENATOR
DODD IN ACTION RELATED TO
WILDFIRES CENTERED ON THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ESTABLISH THE
WILDFIRE TECHNOLOGY RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT REVIEW ADVISORY
BOARD. TO ASSESS AND REPORT ON
THE PROGRESS OF RESULTS OF THE
NEWLY CREATED OFFICE
ADDITIONALLY IT ADDITIONALLY
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TRANSFERRED
THE NEW OFFICE FROM- YES THE
CAL FIRE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
TIME. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACKER
FIVE PORCHES HI BRADFORD HI
BYRON HI CORTESE I DALLY. I
DONT I TORONTO I EGGMAN. GLAZER
ICONS ALL THIS HIGH GROWTH. HI
HURTS BURKE I WAS SO HI HER
TADO. JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I. LEIVA I THE MON. I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON I A CHILL OF
BOTH. HI PAM HI FOURTEEN ZERO.
I. ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
STERN NUMBER ALL RIGHT I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL. HI
SENATOR DODD MOUSSA CALL
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX AFTER
WHICH WILL TAKE THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY NINE AND FORTY SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS READY PLEASE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE CURRENT
PROPERTY TAX EXCLUSION. AND THE
SOLAR FINANCING STRUCTURE CALL
THE PARTNERSHIP FLIP ASTRONAUT.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR A QUESTION THE
OTHER. WOULD YOU ROUTE TICKET
QUESTION CERTAINTY. HE WILL BE
THE CHAIR. WHEN YOU TOOK THE
ASSEMBLY MINUTE AMENDMENTS I
JUST WANNA CONFIRM THAT THIS IS
FOR ONE FLIP NOT MULTIPLE FLIPS
AND THAT WILL. SEVERELY
IMPACTED THOSE THAT- ED USE
THIS FLIPPING STRATEGY TO DO
DIVERSION- ON TAXES AND OTHER
THINGS. I BELIEVE SO IT'S THE
LANGUAGE. THE CURRENT
AMENDMENTS WE'RE ANY
PARTNERSHIP YOU CAN TRIP WITH
THE STORY GIVEN ANY PARTNERSHIP
TRANSACTION UNDER THIS SECTION
SHALL RESULT IN COMPENSATION TO
THE COUNTY. WHICH ONE WHICH
TRANSACTION OCCURS EQUAL TO THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE ANNUAL
PROPERTY TAX LOSS IS CALCULATED
BY THE COUNTY ASSESSOR'S I DO
NOT KNOW IF IT WAS MULTIPLE
FLIPS I HAVE NOT. BUILT INTO IT
THAT DEEPLY I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BUT IT'S- IT'S IN FULL IT
IS INFORMED BY THE POLICY OF
THE STATE WE FIND THROUGHOUT
LEGISLATION WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
RENEWABLES. I KNOW THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED MANY
TIME IN THAT REGARD BUT I CAN'T
TELL YOU WITH GREAT CERTAINTY
THAT YOU ASKED THIS QUESTION
NOW WHETHER IT'S MULTIPLE OR
NOT. OKAY THANK YOU SIR I'M ON
MY OWN TIME SO THE WAY THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS SPECIFY
THAT PROPERTY TAXES COLLISIONS
ONLY APPLIED TO ONE PARTNERSHIP
FLIP TRANSACTION FOR SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS AND CLARIFY THE
EXCLUSION DOES NOT APPLY IF THE
PARTY SALE EXCHANGE OWNERSHIP
OF THE PARTNERSHIP OR LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANY IN THE
TRANSACTION. THAT IS A SEPARATE
FROM THE PARTNERSHIP CLICK
TRANSACTION SO TECHNICALLY I
GUESS IF THERE WAS A
PARTNERSHIP FLIP TRANSACTION MY
UNDERSTANDING BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND I'M JUST ASKING
YOU IF THAT'S YOUR INTENT I
MEAN YEAH THE INTENT OF US IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT YOU KNOW
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN
RESOURCES FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
ON SOLAR STAFF. IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT MULTIPLE FLIPS AND
MULTIPLE PARTNERSHIPS CAN'T
CONTINUE TO DO THAT TO RESTRICT
RESOURCES GOING BACK TO THE
COUNTY AND I JUST WAS GOING TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AMENDMENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY BECAUSE THAT'S THE
WAY I READ IT. BUT I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WAS YOUR INTENT.
ON THAT BRANCH OF MY CLOTHES
RANGE AREA AN- I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT IN THE ASSEMBLY MY
HOPE IS THAT WHAT IS WRITTEN
DOWN IS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR TO PREVENT THAT FROM
BEING AND DESTRUCTIVE AGAINST
COUNTIES THAT PROVIDE SOLAR
ENERGY TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I.
VOTE- IF THE AMENDMENT STANCE.
VERY GOOD IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU QUICKLY JUST
FOR THE RECORD. THERE IS A
FINANCIAL MECHANISM NECESSARY
TO ON THE ONE HAND. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF GETTING INVESTORS
AND FIGURING OUT HOW THAT
FINANCIAL MECHANISMS WORK THIS
LAW HAS BEEN PROPOSED TO
CLARIFY ANY ISSUE WITH RESPECT
TO THAT TRANSFER WE DON'T I
THINK THAT. THAT THAT THE
QUESTION MAY BE THE ANSWER THE
QUESTION MAY BE CORRECT IN THE
SENSE THAT THE PURPOSE WAS NOT
MULTIPLE. BUT I DON'T WANT TO
PUT MYSELF ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE SUCH
SPECIFICS AS SPECIFICITY BUT IT
IS CLEAR THAT IT WAS TO
ACCOMMODATE THIS FINANCING
MECHANISM. THAT ALLOWS US TO
ATTRACT FINANCIAL INVESTORS AT
THE SAME TIME ALLOW THE
TRANSFER. OTHERWISE AND MAKE
THIS MECHANISM WORK WHICH IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO THE FINANCING
STRUCTURE FOR THE SOLAR
PROJECTS THANK YOU.
ASTRONOMICAL. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
I. ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE
NO BACKER. HI FORTUS. BRADFORD
I KERR BY ADAM HI COURTESY HI
DALLY FIVE DOT. FIVE TORONTO I
A COMMON. I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TROUBLE
BOTH. HI PAM I FOURTEEN TINA.
HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER.
FIVE STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW
SKI I WINNER I WILL. HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG MOVES A CALL SENATOR
ROB ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO
REVOKE HERBAL TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEEDS CENTER OFF THE FLOOR IS
pTHIS BILL'S BUCHAN CONCURRENCE
THE MEASURE EXTENDS A SUNSET ON
THE REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEEDS PROGRAM AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY MAKE TECHNICAL
IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
RESPECTFULL AS FOR NOVEL. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SAYING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE. I BACKER. HI FORGES I
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
COURTESY. HI DOLLY I DONT I
TORONTO I EGGMAN HI BLAZER. I
GONZALEZ. I GROSS HI HURTS
BURKE I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
JONES HI I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE.
I MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT I
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
I LIKE ASKING FIVE WINNER I
WELL I. SENATOR ROTH MOVES A
CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY NINE SENATOR DODD HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
TWO BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL LIABILITY
SENATOR DODD THE FLOOR'S YOURS
YEAH MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THIS BILL PROTECTS CERTIFIED
BURN BOSSES FOR BEING CHARGED
FIRE SUPPRESSION COSTS UNLESS
THEY ACTED RECKLESSLY IN
MANAGING. A PERMITTED
PRESCRIBED BURN THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THING NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FACE I BACKER. I
PORCHES I BRADFORD I HAVE A
HIGH COURTS AT THE I. DALI I
DON I DRAW SO I A GUNMAN I
GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE I GROW I
HEARD SOME BURG I WAS SO. I
FURTADO JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. I A TELEVOTE I
CAN HI FOURTEEN TINA. I BROUGHT.
HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG HI I WAKE OUT SKIING I
WINNER. I WILL HI SENATOR DODD
MOVES A CALL. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SENATOR WIENER HE
IS PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THAT ABOUT THREE
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR WIENER
AN ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES
SENATOR WIENER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SP THREE
THIRTY NINE THE GAS TAX
ALTERNATIVE PILOT PROGRAM IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE ROAD CHARGE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. TO
FURTHER STUDY THE EFFICACY
ABOUT SUPPLEMENTATION- FOR A
ROAD USER CHARGE AND CHARGES
FOR DRIVERS BASED ON THE MILES
ARE TRAVELLED AMENDMENTS TAKEN
THE ASSEMBLY CLARIFY CERTAIN
TIMELINES AND STREAMLINE THE
CONSULTATION AMONG AGENCIES-
THIS IS BROUGHT TO POOR AND I
RESPECT BEST FRIEND I HAVE A-
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CENTER GROVE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL- IS THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING RIGHT TO CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL TAX REVENUE AND
REVENUE FOR. ABIT VEHICLES-
TRAVELED IS NOT A GOOD
SITUATION ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
THAT LIVE IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT GOES
FRIEND KERN COUNTY FIVE HOURS
TO THE SOUTH. EAST TO NEEDLES-
A LOT OF OUR PEOPLE THAT TRAVEL
TRAVEL FROM KERN COUNTY TO
TULARE COUNTY INTO RURAL AREAS
IT'S JUST NOT FEASIBLE FOR US
TO BE CHARGE WE WOULD BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE TAXES- ENTER VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED BECAUSE- I MEAN AND- I
MEAN I'M JUST ASSUMING THAT IN
SAN FRANCISCO I MEAN I'M SURE
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT DRIVE CARS IN A LONG
DISTANCE THEY- TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THE BART- BUT I
KNOW THAT. YOU KNOW FOR IN MY
DISTRICT YOU DRIVE EIGHTEEN
MILES TO THE GROCERY STORE FROM
WHERE I LIVE SO I THINK IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
AFFECTS THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
IT AFFECTS RULES A CALIFORNIA
AND WOULD MAKE. CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE
A FAIR TAX BASE WOULD-
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THEM
SO I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER WINNER
YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- I APPRECIATE
THEIR MARKS OUR CALLERS FROM
BAKERSFIELD I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT THE EXACT. OPPOSITE IS
TRUE IN MANY WAYS BECAUSE
CURRENTLY FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TO DRIVE LONG DISTANCES BECAUSE
OF- THE- IT'S A RURAL AREA OR
OR MORE SPREAD OUT AREA. THEY
ARE CURRENTLY PAYING MORE GAS
TAXES THAN PEOPLE WHO DRIVE
SHORT DISTANCES YOU HAVE TO
DRIVE A HUNDRED MILES EVERY
DAY. THEN YOU'RE PAYING A LOT
MORE GAS TAXES THAN SOMEONE IN
AN URBAN SETTING. WHO IS- PAIN
DRIVING FIVE OR TEN MILES A DAY
SO WHETHER IT'S VMT OR GAS TAX
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE DRIVING
LONGER DISTANCES THEY'RE GOING
TO PAY MORE AND THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE WHEN YOU TRANSITION.
FROM GAS TAX TO BE ABOUT MILES
TRAVELLED. I WILL TELL YOU
SPEAKING OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SAN
FRANCISCANS AND OTHER URBAN
DWELLERS WHO WILL BE. IMPACTED
AND PAY MORE BECAUSE OF THE
ANTI BECAUSE THEY HAVE A ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES RIGHT NOW
ANYONE WHO HAS AN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE AND- I WOULD- EXPECT
DISPROPORTIONATELY THAN MY
DISTRICT HAS MORE THAN- CENTER
FROM BAKERSFIELD. KING ZERO IN
GAS TAXES BECAUSE THEY USE NO
GAS. THEY WILL PAY FOR BMT AND
THEY SHOULD BECAUSE THAT IS THE
EQUITABLE THING TO DO BECAUSE
EVEN IF YOU HAVE A ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE. YOU'RE STILL
PUTTING WEAR AND TEAR ON THE
ROADS. THIS IS AN EQUITABLE
APPROACH BUT IN THE END. THIS
IS A STUDY SO WE CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT DO WE DO. AS GAS TAXES
DIMINISH. BECAUSE WE STILL NEED
TO FIX OUR ROADS AND HIGHWAYS
AND SUPPORT OUR TRANSIT
SYSTEMS. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I
FACE NO BACKER I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI HI CORTESE
I DALLY NO DON. FIVE TORONTO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROW. NO HERTZBERG I WISH SO.
FIVE HER TADO. JONES NO ONE CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED. I LLEVA HI
THE MON I REQUIRE. I NO MAN NO
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO CONTROL
BOTH NO PAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA.
I. ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HELLO NOW
SENATOR WIENER MOVES A CALL
MOVING ITEMS ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY ONE FORTY TWO FORTY THREE
AND THEN FORTY FOUR- SENATOR.
I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW BOTH
NO CAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I
ROCKED I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG. I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER FIVE WELL. SENATOR
LIEBERMAN MOVES A CALL ITEM
NUMBER FORTY TWO SENATOR LEYVA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THAT ABOUT THREE SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING
TO VEHICLES CENTER LABOR THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP
THREE SEVENTY TWO IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY EXPANDED
ELIGIBILITY TO INCLUDE A B. SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES ADDED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
SPECIFIED FUNDS BUT MAY BE
ALLOCATED TO THE PROGRAM THIS
BILLS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BOTH. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL- EXCUSE ME IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THAT IS A
LITTLE IMPORTANT DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING THEN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BASE. I BECKER FIVE
PORCHES HI BRADFORD I HAVE A-
LIFE FOR TESTING I DALLY. NO
DODD I DRAW I HAD BEEN I GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATE HI GROVE. I HEARD
SPURRED. WESTERN HI HER TADO
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LABOR I THE MON. HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO- TROUBLE HI PAM FIVE
FOURTEEN TINA. I. ROSS I RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN ON BURKE I
WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER I WILL HI
SENATOR LABOR MOVES THE CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY THREE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY BY SENATOR LAYERED AN
ACT RELATING TO UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SENATOR LITTERED THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WELL THIS IS S. B.
THREE NINETY- BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS IN
DECEMBER WE WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE. THIS BILL REQUIRES E.
D. D. TO CREATE A RECESSION
PLAN. SO THAT WHAT HAPPENED
THIS TIME AND WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE GREAT RECESSION NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN THIS IS ONE OF
THE TWO MAJOR RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR THIS
BILL IMPLEMENTED SO WE WILL BE
READY THE NEXT TIME WITH A PLAN
THAT IS UPDATED REGULARLY AND
TRANSPARENT. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN AUTHORS IN THE
BICAMERAL AUTHORS AND THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I ASKED
FOR MY VOTE IN THE CONCURRENCE
TO THE AMENDMENTS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS I FACE HI BECKER. HI FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI HI COURTESY I DALLY. I
DONT HI THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN I
LASER. I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. I
HURTS BURKE I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA. HI THE MON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA.
HI ROB I RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WELL. HI SENATOR
LAYERED MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO TEMPORARILY- MOOT
BUT NOT TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
FORTY FOUR SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH NUMBER FORTY FIVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SEVEN AND
THEN FILE ON YOUR ITEM NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT- MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. FORTY FIVE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOUR OH THREE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
DRINKING WATER CENTER GONZALEZ
THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO SP FOUR
THREE ADDED IMPORTANT DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSOLIDATION ABOUT RINSE WATER
SYSTEMS INCLUDING REQUIRING
CONSULTATION WITH GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES
CLARIFYING ELIGIBILITY FOR
DOMESTIC WELLS AND REQUIRING
GREATER COMMUNITY AND SYSTEM
AND PUT IN THE DISCUSSIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A VOTE.
FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I FACE NO BACKER. I FOR
JUST. NOPE BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM HI V. I. DALLY. NO DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROSS. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO HI HER TADO. JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE
THE MON I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO
TURBO NO PAM I FORTINO HI RON.
HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN
AMBERG HI I WORK OUT SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL. NOW YES. YEAH
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
I. HI JONES I HATE TO KNOW. BRO
GROVE I. GROVE ROAD NO. GLOBAL
SENATOR GONZALES MOVED TO CALL.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
LAYERED AN ACT RELATING TO
WATER CENTER LEARN THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
pRIGHT BILL BECAUSE THIS RELATES
TO FIRE NOT WATER. A ALL THE
FIRE REQUIRES WATER. IS THAT IS
BEFORE. NINETY SIX. OKAY THEN
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE GOT THANK YOU
THIS BILL THE DISTRICT BUILT
ITS BACK ON CONCURRENCE- IN THE
PAPAROA RIVER IT HAS A EIGHT
YEAR FLOOD PROTECTION RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE REPLYING FOR GRANTS TO
THE STATE AND THIS WILL ALLOW
THEM TO UTILIZE ALL THE GRANTS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AN ASSEMBLY AT
COST SAVING MEASURES AND CREATE
A THRESHOLD FOR PROJECTS TO
MEET. IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I
ASKED FOR MY PHONE SIR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BAIT. FIVE BACKER I
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A
I PROTESTING I DALLY. I DONT. I
TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I DROVE. FIVE
HERTZBERG I WEAR SO I HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON. FIVE MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN
FIVE NIELSEN I A CELLO BOW. HI
PAM HI FOURTEEN TINA. HI RALPH
I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN
NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WINNER I WILL HI. SENATOR
LAYERED MOVES THE CALL OPEN
ONTO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
SENATOR MAN. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
HUNDRED BY SENATOR MAN AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES. SENATOR
MEANT THE FORAGERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SP FIVE HUNDRED
SET ZERO EMISSION TARGETS FOR
THOMAS VEHICLES AS A RESULT OF
A AMENDMENTS MADE IN THE SIMPLY
THE CALCHAMBER INTERNET
ASSOCIATION TECHNET. SELF
DRIVING COALITION SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP L. A.
BUSINESS COUNCIL NET CHOICE
HAVE ALL REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. SO ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. C. NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ADKINS I BAIT. BACKER HI
FORTRESS BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI COURTESY I DALLY NO
DODD. I TORONTO HI A GIVEN FIVE
LASER. HI CONSOLIDATES FIVE
GROVE. NO HERTZBERG I WENT SO.
HI HER TADO JONES NO KAMMERER
FIVE LAYERED I. LEIVA I LIVE
ALONE FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S
NO MEN FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO
A TROUBLED. NO PAN. FOUR TWENTY
NOW. I. ROSS. I RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER FIVE STERN I'M BERG HI
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. WINNER I
WELL. NOW CENTERMAN MOVES A
CALL MOVING I DON'T ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY THEN WE'LL DO
FIFTY ONE. AND FIFTY TWO
SENATOR DODD IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
COMMUNICATIONS. SENATOR DODD
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. A META
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP FIVE FIVE
SIX WHICH SEEKS TO ACCELERATE
THE DEPLOYMENT OF WIRELESS
BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IS BACK FOR FINN
CURRENTS. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ENSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS BY REQUIRING SERVICES
PROMOTE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
MONITOR THEIR PROGRESS TOWARDS
REACHING CALIFORNIA'S UNIVERSAL
BROADBAND GOALS BY REPORTING
WIRELESS BROADBAND COVERAGE BY
CENSUS TRACT IN LEADER
LEGISLATURE THIS WAS IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY MY CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES AND OTHER MEMBERS
WHEN I BROUGHT IT UP IN THIS
HOUSE. BEFORE WE WERE ABLE TO
GET THAT AMENDMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'LL VOTE
ON THIS CRITICALLY NEEDED
LEGISLATION FOR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING MAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE EIGHT
NO BACKER. I PORCHES BRADFORD.
FIVE BY ADAM ON HI PROTESTING.
HI DALLY NO DODD HI I ASSUME HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER. GONZALES I
GROW NO IT'S A VERY HI WEST SO
HI HER TADO JONES I CAN LONGER
YEAH. WHERE DO. I LIVE ON I
LIVE ALONE. MCGUIRE. NO
MELINDA'S. MAN FIRST THING FOR
THE SYSTEM HI I. NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT I NIELSEN. I A TELEPHONE.
HI PAM I FOURTEEN TINO. I. ROSS.
I RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG HI I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER ALL RIGHT I WILL. NOW
SENATOR DODDMOOSE CALL MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE
SENATOR GONZALES. FOURTEEN HE
IS READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
ONE BY SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE PERCENT SP SIX
SEVENTY ONE FOR CONCURRENT
ADVANCES CLEAN FREIGHT THAT IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING
pINEQUITIES IN EMISSIONS
OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES THE
BILL TOOK MINOR TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASPEN I VOTE. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. DISCUSSION DEBATING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE HI
BECKER. FIVE FORTUS FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. HI
CORTESE I DALLY I DONT HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER. FIVE
TEN DOLLARS FIVE GROVE HI HURTS
BERG. I WENT SO. HI HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
FIVE LLEVA. I LIVE ALONE HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON I A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I PERSON TINA. HI
RALPH. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE V.
I. WINNER I WILL HI. SENATOR
GONZALEZ MOVED TO CALL MEMBERS
I WONDER IT REMIND YOU IF YOU
NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
THAT YOU GO TO THE BACK AND-
KEEP DOWN THE NOISE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT HARD TO HEAR APPEAR-
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO-
TEMPORARILY PASSED ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY TWO AND FIFTY THREE MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR.
IT SENATOR SKINNER. WHAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIXTEEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
AN ACT RELATING TO PEACE
OFFICERS SENATOR SKINNER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP
SIXTEEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
MAYBE WE HAVE A TWO TWO TIMES A
CHARM VERSUS THREE TIMES THIS
IS THE BILL. THAT PASSED BOTH
HOUSES LAST YEAR BUT SHE ASKED
ME THIS IS THE NECK OF THE
MIDNIGHT DEADLINE. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENT SPECIFIED THAT
RECORDS RELATED TO USE OF
EXCESSIVE AND UNREASONABLE
FORCE MUST BE SUSTAINED. AND IT
CLARIFIES PROVISIONS REGARDING
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE THIS
IS A GOOD MEASURE WHICH ALLOWS
WHICH WILL HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE
TRUST BETWEEN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. D. THREE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NOPE BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM ARE YOU PROTESTING HI
DALLY. NO DOT I TORONTO I
EGGMAN FIVE BLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. NO HURTS
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
JONES. NO KIM WALKER I LAYERED
I LLEVA HI THE MON. REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO ULTRABOOK. PAN HI
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT. FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN- BERG
HI KELSEY I WINNER I WELL NOW.
SENATOR SKINNER MOVES THE CALL
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINETEEN BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES CENTER
GREATER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- SP NINETEEN IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE UP WITH MANY OF
YOU OKAY. WE WORK VERY HARD TO
HELP OUR WINERIES AND IN
PARTICULAR ARE SMALL WINERIES
AND THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY THAT
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ADDED AN
APPLICATION FEE FOR DUPLICATE
WINE GROWERS LICENSE THE BILLS
ARE SUPPORTED BY A COALITION OF
WINERIES AND BUSINESS GROUPS
HAD. HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ALL
THE WAY ALONG THE LINE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THIRTY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE. I
BECKER. HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI FOR TESTING
FIVE DALLY. I DONT I TORONTO HI
ADNAN HI PLEASE SIR I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH I HEARD
SEBERG. WESTERN HI HER TADO
JONES I CAN'T LONGER I LAYERED
I. LEIVA HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN. HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN.
FOURTEEN TINA. HI RALPH I RUBIO.
SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER I LIKE
HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI
SENATOR GLACIER MOVES THE CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO TEMPORARILY PASS
ITEM FIFTY SIX AND MOVE ON TO
ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN SENATOR LAYERED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOUR FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
LAYERED AN ACT RELATING TO FIRE
PREVENTION. ENTER LAYERED THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS ABOUT A FIRE.
IN OUR HEARTS. IS DOMINATING
THE STATE RIGHT NOW AND WHAT WE
HAVE DONE FOR FIRE PREVENTION
HAS BEEN WHATEVER WE HAVE PUT
IN THE BUDGET EVERY YEAR WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS SAYS WE WILL
HAVE A MULTI YEAR PLAN. THAT
TAKES THE GOALS OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOALS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE CAN PLAN
YEAR TO YEAR FOUR AND WE CAN
MEASURE WHAT'S BEEN DONE AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE WHAT'S BEEN
DONE AND FEELS MANAGEMENT
WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN FORCE
MANAGEMENT. OF THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY OR
TECHNICAL ANOTHER CO AUTHOR-
THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I
ASKED FOR AN AUTOGRAPH.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTERED
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AS AS MANY YOU
KNOW. THE DIXIE FIRE- AND NOW
THE CALIBER FIRE HAS CONSUMED
IN MY DISTRICT BURNED OVER A
MILLION ACRES IN THE LAST. SIX
WEEKS. AND SOMEOF THE
FRUSTRATIONS THAT WE FINDAN IN
THE AGENCIES WE HAVE CAL FIRE
WHO TAKES CARE OF STATE LANDS.
WE HAVE THE FOR SERVICE AND THE
B. L. M. IN THE PARK SERVICES
THAT TAKE CARE OF THE FEDERAL
LANDS. AND THERE'S CONFLICT
BETWEEN HOW THEY EVEN OPERATE.
FOR SERVICE MANAGES FIRES. THEY
DON'T PUT HIM OUT SO HUGE
PROBLEM WE HAVE TO WAIT
ACTUALLY CAL FIRE SAID
SOMETIMES AND WAITS FOR THE
FIRE BEFORE THEY CAN ENGAGE.
WHEN I GET ON STATE PROPERTY.
JUST LAST WEEK- AND I'VE BEEN
TOURING MY FIRES I'VE BEEN
LOOKING IN MY COMMUNITIES AND I
AND WE HAVE. INTERACTION
BETWEEN STATE LANDS IN FEDERAL
LANDS AND SO LAST WEEK. AND I
AND I GETTING VIDEOS. FROM
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY OUT THERE
FIGHTING THE FIRE CONTRACTORS
BUT WE HAVE DOZERS SITTING.
BULLDOZERS ON TRUCKS SITTING AS
A BUYER'S APPROACHING HOUSE AND
I HAVE PRIVATE CITIZENS.
FIGHTING FIRE ON THEIR OWN LAND
IN THE DOES ARE MOVING. SO THIS
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WHERE WHAT
IS THE POLICIES WE'VE HEARD.
THAT THE GET THE PRESS THAT THE
GOVERNOR ASKED THE PRESIDENT TO.
PUSH HARDER THAT. THE FOREST
SERVICE ACTUALLY PUT FIRES OUT.
SO I JUST WANT TO LET THE
CENTERS NO ACTUALLY WENT ON
SUNDAY AND TOOK MY FIRE CLASS I
HAVE THE CAR NOW TO BE ABLE TO
GO OUT AND FIGHT ON A FIRE AND
I'M GONNA DO THAT WHEN WEGET
OUT OF SESSION I'M GONNA GO
ACTUALLY HIEROCLES CONTRACTOR
SO I CAN SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND. SO WE CAN
HOPEFULLY STOP THESE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE BURNING UP.
MILLIONS OF ACRES THERE'S
HABITATS WILDLIFE IT'S OUR
WATERSHED. AS WE'RE DOING BILLS
TODAY SITTING HERE TALKING
ABOUT. TRANSPORTATION IN THE
MISSIONS THAT COME UP IN
TRANSFORMATIONS WHICH THESE
FIRES DWARF. AND WE SPEND VERY
LITTLE RESOURCES. ON ACTUALLY
PREVENTING FIRE IN TAHOE. THE
REASON WHEN IT CAME IN A
CHRISTMAS VALLEY THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO BACKFIRE IS BECAUSE WE
PUT IN FUEL BREAKS THERE AND
ALLOWTHE FIREFIGHTERS TO COME
IN AND SET THE BACKFIRE TO BURN
THE FUEL WAY SO WE CAN ACTUALLY
SAVE OUR COMMUNITIES WE NEED
THAT IN EVERY COMMUNITY.
THROUGHOUT YOUR DISTRICTS
WHETHER IT'S CHAPARRAL AND
BRUSH OR TREES SO I'M SUPER
EXCITED ABOUT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I WANTED TO
ACTUALLY WORK THOUGH WE NEED TO
NOT JUST TALK ABOUT IT. WE'RE
GONNA BE FACING THIS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. WE SEE A RED FLAG
WARNINGS WE'VE SEEN DRY FUELS.
WE HAD NO RAIN. AND WHAT WE DO
WE SPEND MOST OF OUR RESOURCES
ON INCENTIVIZING SOMEBODY TO
HAVE ELECTRIC VEHICLE IS NOT
GONNA DO ANYTHING. TO STOP THE
POLLUTION AND THE DESTRUCTION
OF CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
RESOURCE WHICH IS OUR
WATERSHEDS SO I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORFOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AS YOU CAN TELL I'M
SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATED I'VE BEEN.
FOR TEN YEARS. TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A BETTER WAY TO DO WHAT WE
DO AND WE HAVE TO HAVE. WE HAVE
TO HAVE A PARTNERSHIP A TRUE
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE FEDERAL
WITH THE FEDS BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BURN AND IT'S REALLY OUT OF
CONTROL THANK YOU. FOR BRINGING
THIS MAJOR FOREIGN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN IPHONE S.
B. FOUR FIVE SIX. SENATOR
NIELSEN. QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
YOUR LEAD WILL YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION OF COURSE I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S ANY SUCH
PROVISION IN THIS BILL BUT I'D
LIKE TO CLARIFY THERE IS AN
UNFORTUNATE PROVISION IN THE
BUDGET THAT I HOPE WE'RE GOING
TO GET REPEALED BEFORE THE
SESSION ENDS. THAT SAYS THE
EXPENDITURE OF A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR SOME WHILE AND
MANAGEMENT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE DETERMINATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT IS
COOL NEEDED. AT WE'VE GOT TO
GET THAT OUT OF THE BUDGET DOES
THAT IS THAT IN THIS BILL THAT
PROVISION GIVING THE AUTHORITY
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BRANCH
NUMBER THERE'S NOTHING ALONG
THOSE LINES IN THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER LAYERED YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS BY OUR COLLEAGUES
AND LET ME MAKE TWO QUICK
POINTS. OF WHEN I WAS AT
NATURAL RESOURCES ALMOST HALF
OF THE MONEY THAT WE SPENT ON
FIRE PREVENTION FROM GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUNDS WENT TO
FEDERAL FORCE WE STEPPED IN WE
DID THAT ON THIS FLOOR EARLIER
THIS WEEK WE ADOPTED A BILL- OR
SEND IT BACK I THINK MAYBE IT
IS SIMPLY THAT REALLY BEEFED UP
THE GOOD NEIGHBOR AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THE STATE
COULD. COULD STEP IN AND
SENATOR DOLLY IS RIGHT WHEN I
WAS RESOURCES SECRETARY HAT
CREEK IN HIS DISTRICT- HAD A
FIRE THAT WOULD BURN OUT IN
CALIFORNIA OF THE FEDERAL LANDS
AND CALIFORNIA WOULD MOVE IN
AND BEAT IT BACK. AND IN THE
END THEY LOST THE MAJOR
BUILDING IN HAT CREEK BECAUSE
OF THAT AND ENTER AND SO-
THAT'S WHY THESE GOOD NEIGHBOR
DEALS ARE GOOD AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S GOOD IN THIS BILL TO PLAN
SO WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
WHERE WE'RE OING AND HOW WE'RE
DOING AND WE CAN PUSH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
APPROPRIATELY THEIR SUPPORT. ON
BOTH SIDES I ASKED FOR AN
IPHONE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I BASE I RECORD. I
PORCHES. HI BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI COURTESY I DALLY FIVE
DODD. FIVE THERE ARE SO. FIVE
EGGMAN. I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE.
GROVE HI HURTS BERG. WESTERN HI
HER TADO JONES I CAN LONGER.
FIVE LAYERED I. LEIVA HI THE
MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN
I NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN I A SHOW
ABOUT HI PAM I PERSON TINA. I.
ROSS I RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN I'M BURKE HI HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER. I WILL. HI
THE- SENATE- CENTER LAYERED
MUSICAL. MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON ITEM NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR MENENDEZ IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR MELINDA
AS AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
SAFETY SENATOR MELINDA IS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING SENATORS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT SP SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN TWENTY TWO. WHICH
IS NAME ALEX'S LIFE AFTER
STUDENT IN MY DISTRICT WHO
DROWNED AT A SCHOOL EVENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY
NARROWED THE BILL SB SEVEN
TWENTY TWO WILL PREVENT FURTHER
TRAGEDIES BY REQUIRING AN ADULT
SUPERVISOR WITH UPDATED CPR
CERTIFICATION TO BE PRESENT AT
AN ON CAMPUS SCHOOL EVENTS.
TAKING PLACE IN OR AROUND THE
SWIMMING POOL THE BILL IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE NEWS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. SIR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE I
BETTER. I PORCHES WELL I
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T HI
CORTEZ I. DALI. HI TODD HI
TORONTO. EGGMAN GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE I DROVE. HERTZBERG
I WISH SO HI HER TADO JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA.
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN
I FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE STERN
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY I WINNER. HI
WELL I. SENATOR MOVES THE CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE SENATOR
CAFIERO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR KERR BIO AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS SOON
RECOVER EURO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS PLEASE TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN FOURTEEN TO
CONCUR IN ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER COVER%
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
pNONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ADKINS FIVE BATES.
BACKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM I FOR TESTING I
DALLY NO DOT. FIVE ZERO ZERO
FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS. HERTZBERG
I WENT SO I HER TADO JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED FIVE LLEVA
I THE MON I WIRE I MELINDA'S NO
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO
WHICH ARE BOTH. PAM I FORTUNE
TINO. I. ROSS I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN I'M BURKE HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER. I
WILL. SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS
MOVING ON THE FILE AND I'M
FIFTY SIX ALSO SENATOR
CABALLERO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR KABBADI
AUTO AN ACT RELATING TO THE
HEALTHY OUTCOMES AND PREVENTION
EDUCATION ACT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
UNDERCOVER HERO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS THE-
MEASURE THAT OUT CREATES A- TAX
ON VAPING PRODUCTS. THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
EXTEND THE FUNDED TWO NEW
HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS AND ALSO-
THE BILL WILL ALLOW US TO
OBTAIN INFORMATION IN ORDER TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM IN THE
FUTURE THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
YOUR I. EIGHT CONCURRING. WITH
THE A SENTIMENT ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I HATE. NO BACKER. I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE
I DALLY. NO TODD I TORONTO I
EXAMINED I PLEASE SIR I
CONSOLIDATE I GROSS NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO JONES NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED FIVE LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TROUBLED.
NO PAN HI PERSON TINA I ROSS I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
NOW. SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO. ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
ITEMS. STARTING OFF WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FIVE ON
MOVING ON TO SIXTY NINE SEVENTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SIX SO START
OFF. WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY FIVE SENATOR ALLEN IT'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT RELATIVE
TO CIVIL LEVEL RISE AWARENESS
MONTH SENATOR ALLEN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ACCORDING TO
A RECENT US GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
REPORT ESTIMATES THAT UP TO TWO
THIRDS OF OUR BEACHES IN THE
STATE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COULD VANISH WITHIN THE
CENTURY. SEA LEVEL RISE- AS
IT'S NOW BEEN ABOUT A SIX POINT
FIVE INCHES SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTY NEARLY HALF THAT RISE
HAVING OCCURRED IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS- SO WE'RE SEEING
RISE IN SAN FRANCISCO ORANGE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO. WITH OVER
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
LIVING NEAR THE SEA IN OVER A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF PROPERTY ALONG THE COAST
THIS RESOLUTION CALLS ATTENTION
TO SEA LEVEL RISE BY DECLARING
MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SEA LEVEL
RISE AWARENESS MONTH AND
RECOGNIZES ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE WORKING TO PRESERVE. OUR
COASTLINE I RESPECT FAST WHEN I
VOTE. MEMBERS IS IT IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN MADAM PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI I.
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS FIVE BASE I
BACKER HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI CORTESE I DALLY. DOT
I TORONTO I ARGUMENT HI GLAZER
I CONSOLIDATE I GROSS.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI FURTADO
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR HI THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. HI A TELEPHONE I CAN I
FORTINO HI RALPH ALL RIGHT
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. HI SENATOR ALLEN MOVED
THE CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY NINE SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN BERMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO BUSINESS
REGULATIONS SENATOR HERTZBERG
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. YOU KNOW
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO MANY
OF THE MEASURES THAT WE
CONSIDER ON THIS FLOOR DEAL
WITH THE COMPLEXITIES OF
GOVERNMENT AND ACRONYMS THAT NO
ONE KNOWS WHAT THEY REALLY
MEAN. AND PROGRAMS THAT WE
ESTABLISH TO IMPACT LIVES THIS
BILL BEFORE US TODAY HERE'S A
BILL THAT I DID SOME YEARS AGO
THE DEALS WITH ONE OF THE
EVERYDAY CHALLENGES THAT WE ALL
FACE CANCELING SUBSCRIPTIONS
ONLINE. I REMEMBER I TRIED TO
CANCEL A SUBSCRIPTION ONCE SAID
TO GO OUT AND THEY SEND YOU A
POSTCARD FOR THIS BILL THIS TWO
THINGS IT ALLOWS YOU TO IF YOU
GO ONLINE ALLOWS THE CANCEL
ONLINE IT ALSO REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO NOTIFY FOLKS
BEFORE THEY AUTOMATICALLY RENEW
KIND OF BASIC CONSUMER COMMON
SENSE STUFF ASKED HERE I VOTE.
THROUGH ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE. I
BACKER HI FORTUS HI BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI CORTEZ V. I.
DALI HI TODD. I ALSO I EXAMINED
EYE LASER. I CONSOLIDATE FIVE
GROVE I HURTS BERG I WAS SO I
HER TADO JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I FLAVOR FIVE THE MON I
AM A WIRE HI MELINDA'S I MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. I A TOTAL OF
BOTH I CAN I PORT AND YOU KNOW.
HI RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I'M BURKE HI MIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER I WILL. HI. SENATOR
HERTZBERG MOVES A CALL MOVING
ITEM ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE CENTER GOOD SOLID IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY AN ACT RELATING TO
ZONING. CENTER CONSOLES FOR
YEARS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF RISE 2% EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY WHICH
WILL HELP BUILD THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
ELECTRIC VEHICLES I CALIFORNIA
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB TWELVE
THIRTY SIX TO STREAMLINE THE
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR. THE
CONSTRUCTION OF EIGHTY
CHARGERS- CHARGING STATIONS
EVERY. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY WILL
RESOLVE NONCOMPLIANCE WITH AB
TWELVE THIRTY SIX BY
ESTABLISHING A CLEAR TIME FRAME
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REVIEW
PERMIT APPLICATIONS FOR EASY
CHARGING STATIONS I THINK YOU
KNOW RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN
RIVAL. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ADKINS I FACE. BACKER FIVE
FOUR JUST NO BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DOLLY NO DOG
I TORONTO. I EXAMINED EYE LASER
I GONZALEZ I GROSS NO HERTZBERG.
I WAS SO I FURTADO JONES. NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO A TURBO NO PAN I
FORTINO I RALPH I RUBIO I
SKINNER FIVE STERNE AMBERG I Y.
CASKEY I WINNER. I WILL NO.
SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES THE CALL
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE AFTER WHICH WILL TAKE UP
SEVENTY SIX AND THEN EIGHTY
SENATOR ROB IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO MASSAGE THERAPY
CENTER UP TO FOUR YEARS THINK
ABOUT A PRESIDENT THIS IS A
SUNSET BILL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL
EXTENDING THE COUNCIL SUNSET
DATE BY ONE YEAR THE BILL
STATES IT'S THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENT TO CONTINUE DISCUSSION
AROUND ISSUES RAISED DURING THE
COUNCIL SUNSET HEARING OVER THE
PAST YEAR AND OVER THE NEXT
YEAR RATHER. THE GOAL IS TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
THROUGH THE SUNSET PROCESS
WHICH WE ALL KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE. IS A TOUGH.
THOROUGH LOOK AT BOTH THE PROS
AND THE CONS OF ANY LICENSE AND
BOARD IN THE MEANTIME THIS
REPORT THIS BILL PRESERVES THE
STATUS QUO. AND AS A RESULT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEVEN
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YEAH
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS HI
BABES I BACKER. I PORCHES I
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI HI
COURTESY FIVE DALLY I DON. HI
TORONTO. EGGMAN I. GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROWTH I HURTS
BURKE I WAS SO. I HER TADO I
JONES. I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN
NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI FI CASKEY I
WINNER. I WELL I. THE MEMBERS
WE DO HAVE A FULL HOUSE WILL
CALL THE ROLL CALL ONE MORE
TIME AND EVERYBODY CAN RESPOND
AT HAS NOT- PLEASE CALL THE OB
TO MEMBERS. TORONTO I STERN.
THE ONE I CANNOT VOTING OKAY.
YEAH. VERY GOOD NO CHANGE ON
THAT OUR MEMBERS. I. FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY SIX ONE OR
MIND YOU ALL THAT- WE'RE GOING
TO BE MOVING THROUGH THIS TWICE
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE
ROLE- ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTY SIX
CENTER ALLEN IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
RELATIVE TO COASTAL AND MARINE
WATERS. THANK YOU TO PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THAT I RISE TO PRESENT
EACH YEAR TO WHICH WILL CALL
UPON CONGRESS AND THE FEDERAL
EPA TO TAKE ALL MEASURES
NECESSARY TO PREVENT. THE DDT
DUMPING SITE OFF THE COAST OF
OUR SANDALS FROM CAUSING
FURTHER HARM TO OUR OCEANS IN
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS. DDT IS
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE FIRST
MAJOR ECOLOGICAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH DISASTERS IN HISTORY OF
CHEMICAL ENGINEERING. PEOPLE
EXPOSED TO LONG TERM DDT OFTEN
DEVELOP PERMANENT NERVOUS
SYSTEM DAMAGE AND IF PREGNANT
THEY CAN. THEY CAN INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF PREMATURE BIRTHS
NATURAL WILDLIFE. EFFECTS OF
DDT ARE BELIEVED TO LEAD TO THE
DISAPPEARANCE OF NUMERACY BIRDS
FROM THE CHANNEL ISLANDS
INCLUDING SPECIES OF CALLS
PELICANS AND CORMORANTS. ARE
MOST DEPRESSING WAS TO SEE OUR
BEAUTIFUL NATIONAL SYMBOL THE
BALD EAGLE- SO THAT THEIR THEIR
LITTLE BAGS. THANK SHELL SO
TERRIBLY DAMAGED. NOW WHY DO
THIS HAPPEN HOW DID THIS HAPPEN.
WELL IT TURNS OUT THAT FOR A
LONG TIME THERE WAS A
PARTICULAR COMPANY THAT WAS
SIMPLY JUST DUMPING. BARRELS
AND BARRELS- IT WE'VE WE'VE NOW
WITH THE ESTIMATES NOW WITH
RECENT MAPPING FROM NO- AND-
RESEARCHERS FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA SUGGESTED THAT MORE
THAN TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
BARRELS. OF DDT WASTE WERE
DUMPED. OFF FAR SHORT. MAKING
IT ONE OF THE LARGEST SOURCES
OF CONTAMINANTS IN THE ENTIRE
PACIFIC OCEAN. SO THIS IS AN
ENORMOUS PROBLEM THE LA TIMES
TODAY A FASCINATING AND VERY
DEPRESSING- EXPOSE ON THIS
ISSUE. WE'VE GOT ENORMOUS
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH REMEDIATING I.
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES THESE
BARRELS ARE SO DEEP IN THE
OCEAN THAT THEY'RE VERY HARD TO
GET TO AND EVEN JUST LIFTING
THEM UP MAY END UP STIRRING UP
SO MUCH TO DO THAT IT WOULD BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. SO WE NEED
FEDERAL ACTION WE NEED FEDERAL
HELP THAT'S WHAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS ALL ABOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
ABOUT OUR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
ANY DISCUSSION OF OUR DEBATE.
SAYING MAN THIS IS ELIGIBLE.
I'M SORRY SENATOR BATES. AT
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANTED
TO ADD MY STRONG SUPPORT OF AG
ARE TIED TO OUR FAMILY IT WAS
NO ACCIDENT IT'S A WORSE
INTENTIONAL ACT THAT SHOWCASES
THE WORST OF CORPORATE GREED
AND GOVERNMENT FAILURE DDT IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO LEAK OUT
AND PERSIST OFF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S WATERS WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT INTERVENTION THAT'S
WHY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE UNITED STATES THROUGH THE
SUPERFUND PROGRAM CAN TO CLEAR
MORE OF THE AREA IS
CONTAMINATED AND BEGAN WHAT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY LONG AND
DIFFICULT PROCESS TO REMEDIATE
THE SEAT. THE FIGHT
CALIFORNIA'S- COASTAL AND
MARINE WATERS ARE AMONG THE
STATE'S MOST PRECIOUS RESOURCES
AND THEIR CONSERVATION AS WE
KNOW WITH THE FINANCIAL AID TO
THE PRESERVATION OF MARINE
WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA'S THRIVING
OCEAN ECONOMY OF FISHING
TOURISM COMMERCE AND RECREATION
SECTORS ALL OF WHICH BORDER MY
DISTRICT IN SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
ALL THE WORK SHOULD BEGIN NOW
SO THERE'S NO FURTHER DELAY IN
THE F. UNBELIEVABLE INEXCUSABLE
ENVIRONMENTAL TRAGEDY SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT- THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY FOR TO OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINGING AND NONE IS
CENTER ALLEN IS THERE ANYTHING
ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO I JUST WANT
TO THINK VERY CAPABLE OF
INFORMAL QUALITY CODE THE VICE
CHAIR- CENTER BAITS FOR VERY
GOOD COMMENTS AND ASK FOR FAST
FOR ONE SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION. VERY GOOD
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
MEMBERS TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY.
SENATOR DOLLY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER
DOLLY THE FORAGERS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I HERE
TO PRESENT EIGHTY NINE FOURTEEN
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHATEVER. MAYBE NINETY FOURTEEN
WILL PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE
WITH IMPORTANT INFORMATION
REGARDING THE EXTENT TO WHICH
FIRST TIME FRESHMEN ARE
PREPARED TO SUCCEED IN
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. THE BILL REQUIRES THE
CS YOU TO SUBMIT AN ANNUAL
REPORT THAT PROVIDES A SUMMARY
OF THE DATA ON COMPLETE ON
COMPLETION RATES CREDITS EARNED
AND GPA DURING A STUDENT'S
FIRST THREE SEMESTERS. THIS
DATA WILL HELP THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINE HOW TO IMPROVE
COLLEGE READINESS PROGRAMS AND
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS ACROSS THE
CSU SYSTEM AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE AWAY. FROM OUR OUTDATED.
THE DEAL MODEL. THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND IS RECEIVING
NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BOTH ON A. B. NINE
FOURTEEN. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
ANY OBJECTION SAYING NINE FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SIX SENATOR
WEST SO. ITEM NUMBER. EIGHTY
SIX. THANK THAT'S ON FILE. VERY
GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO I CAME
HERE AS IT IS A LINE UP OF THE
NUMBERS FOLKS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN AND THEN ITEM NUMBER ONE
OH NINE. WE'RE GONNA PASS ON
FILE ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT. MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN. SENATOR LAYERED
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ. THE.
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY AS AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES
CENTER LATER THE FOUR YEARS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
PRESIDENT- THIS IS A. B. EIGHT
FORTY NINE WHICH PROTECTS THE
RIGHTS OF SENIORS LIVING IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES BY
CLARIFYING THAT UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN DAMAGES CAN
BE AWARDED- PER VIOLATION OF
RIGHTS RATHER THAN IN TOTAL OF
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN. IN
DECEMBER INSURE THAT DAMAGES
ARE PROPORTIONATE TO THE
SEVERITY OF VIOLATIONS AND MAKE
THE BILL APPLICABLES FOR MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FORWARD IN
RESPONSE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND THE DOCTORS COMPANY HAVE
TAKEN A NEUTRAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL THIS WILL BALANCE THE
SCALES OF JUSTICE I ASKED FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. THREE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATTENDEES I. BACKER I PORCHES
NO BRADFORD. CABRERA I E. I.
DALI NO DODD I TORONTO I
EXAMINED EYE LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I FURTADO I
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON FIVE WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO THE TROUBLE. PAN HI
HI PARTS AND TINA I BROUGHT. HI
STERN I'M BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE
E. I. WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BASICS
NOW. BRADFORD JONES. THE
TROUBLE. STERN. FIVE TWENTY
NINE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR WIENER IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE TWENTY THREE BY
SEVEN MEMBER CHOLERA AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES
SENATOR WIENER THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CALLING- SO WE BUILT THREE
TWENTY THREE ESTABLISHES. A
CLEAR STANDARD NECESSARY TO
HOLD LICENSED LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DEATHS BECAUSE UNDER THE
REGULATORY DUTY OF CARE.
ADDITIONALLY SP THREE TWENTY
THREE ADOPTED STATE AUDITOR
AUDITOR RECOMMENDATION TO
INCREASE- THE CDPH PENALTY
AMOUNTS FOR THESE FACILITIES-
THAT PENALTY NOT HAVING BEEN
CHANGED FOR TWENTY YEARS SO
IT'S IN NEED OF A- REVISION TO
REFLECT. INFLATION ETCETERA
MOVING FORWARD ROBUST AND CLEAR
NURSING HOME OVERSIGHT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
WILL BE CRITICAL FOR TO AVERT
TRAGEDIES LIKE THOSE
EXPERIENCED DURING THE COVER
NINETEEN ONGOING PANDEMIC-
CLASS DOUBLE A. CITATIONS ARE
THE MOST SERIOUS- TYPE IN OUR
ONLY ISSUE TO CDPH CREWS. THAT
THE FACILITIES ACTIONS AND
HEARING TO REGULATIONS- OVER
THE CALL OR OR IN NOT IF YOU'RE
IN THE REGULATIONS WERE THE
CAUSE OF A RESIDENCE STAFF. THE
CURRENT CAR QUOTE DIRECT
PROXIMATE CAUSE LEGAL STANDARD
IN STATUTE. HAS CAUSED
INCONSISTENCY IN THE
APPLICATION OF THE CITATIONS
THIS IRREGULARITY AROSE BECAUSE
COURTS HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
DIRECT PROXIMATE CAUSE IS
CONFUSING AND UNCLEAR. IN FACT
THE SUPREME COURT HAS REJECTED
THE APPLICATION APPROXIMATE
BECAUSE- AT WHICH IS CAUSE
ADDITIONAL CONFUSION. ON IN
ADDITION THE PENALTY AMOUNTS
ARE TOO LOW TO DETER- ARE
UNSAFE BEHAVIOR. AND SO WE NEED
TO UPDATE THOSE AMOUNTS- COLORS.
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY. OR
DEBATE ON ITEM. DISCUSSION
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FACE. BACKER FIVE FOUR
JUST. BRADFORD I COME BY OTHER
HI CORTESE HI DOLLY. DODD HI
THERE ALSO I EXAMINED EYE LASER.
I CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI TANTO HI
JONES NO KAMMERER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. OCTOBER CAN I FORTUNE
TINO I BROUGHT I RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER ALL
RIGHT I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. FACE PORGES.
DALLY NOW. GROVE NO MELINDA'S
NO NIELSEN NO. A TROUBLED NO.
STERN. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS NO
SEVEN. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA GO BACK TO
THE UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF BILLS THAT ARE LEFT
ON ITEM NUMBER. FORTY SERVICES
THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND HER
DAUGHTER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO DATE WE HAVE SP
THREE NINE THREE THE FORMER
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE ACT BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THE BILL-
ALIGNS THE MICRO CHILD CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS FUNDING STREAM
WITH OTHER VOUCHER BASED
PROGRAMS THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY INTENT TO
RESOLVE- CHATTERING OUT ISSUES
THIS BILL HAS AN OPPOSITION
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I S.
FOR. RESPECTFUL PRINT ABOUT.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MEMBERS THISITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING NONE ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY TWO
SENATOR HER TITLE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN OH THREE BY SENATOR
HER TADO AN ACT RELATING TO
DISEASED ANIMALS SENATOR HER
TADO THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU SENATE BILL SEVEN ZERO
THREE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE POULTRY LIVESTOCK LAB
SAFETY ACT ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE TECHNICAL CLARIFYING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. QUESTION
OR DEBATE THING NINE. MEMBERS
THIS IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
OTHER UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SAY
NINETY IVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING BACK
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING THE
NEXT ITEM IS I FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE OH NINE AFTER WHICH WILL
TAKE UP ONE TWELVE. AND THEN.
ONE SIXTEEN. SENATOR RUBIO IS
READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOHN
SAWYER AND AFTER RELATING TO
LONG TERM HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES SENATOR RUBIO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS COLLEAGUES IN
THE SENATE I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AT TEN FORTY TO TWENTY
FIRST EIGHTY AND CRITICAL CARE
FOR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS NURSING HOMES HAVE
BECOME THE MOST DANGEROUS PLACE
TO LIVE DURING THESE COLD IT
NINETEEN TIMES. WITH NEARLY
THIRTEEN THOUSAND LIVES LOST
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THE
STATE HAVE THE PROPER TOOLS TO
COLLECT UNPAID FEES FROM
COMPANIES AND INCENTIVIZES ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED TO PROVIDE.
QUALITY PATIENT CARE AT TEN
FORTY TWO IS SPONSORED BY SEIU
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NOT ABLE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
SIDE OF MEMBERS. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALL RIGHT I ARCHULETA I
ADKINS FIVE BASE NO BACKER HI
HI FORGES. NO BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM I FOR TESTING HI DOLLY
NO DOG. I YOU'RE AWESOME HI
ADNAN HI GLAZER HI FRIENDS
AULUS HIGH GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. I FURTADO I JONES
NOPE CAN'T LONGER. I LAYERED HI
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO- TROUBLE NO PAN HI
PORTS AND TINA. HI RALPH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN I'M
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL KNOW. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER. ONE TWELVE.
SENATOR HER TADO SHE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG
RELATIVE TO VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS MONTH CENTRE HER
DAUGHTER THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY
I'M PROUD TO RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG TO PRESENT
ACR FIFTY EIGHT DEDICATING THE
MONTH OF AUGUST AS VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS MONTH. VALLEY FEVER
IS A LONG INFECTION
CROSSBREEDING INNATE DESERT
FUNGUS THAT GROWS IN THE SOIL
AND SPREADS AIRBORNE THROUGH
THE WIND WHILE SOME CASES
PROVED TO BE RELATIVELY MINOR
THE CDC ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY
40% OF VALLEY FEVER CASES LEAD
TO HOSPITALIZATION. AND TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE WAS A RECORD
HIGH TOTAL OF NINE THOUSAND AND
FOUR VALLEY FEVER CASES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH OVER
HALF PRESENT IN MY DISTRICT.
HAS VALLEY FEVER CONTINUES TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY THREATEN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IT IS
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT TO
PROMOTE BEST PRACTICES AND
INNOVATIVE TREATMENTS TO COME
TO COMBAT THIS POTENTIALLY
DEVASTATING DISEASE. VALLEY
FEVER AWARENESS MONTH IS A
POWERFUL REMINDER OF WHY WE
MUST INCREASE FUNDING FOR
RESEARCH FOCUS ON THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN. ANIMALS
SOILS PLANTS AND HUMANS SO THAT
WE ARE BETTER PREPARED TO
HANDLE FUTURE PANDEMICS AND
DISEASES AND SO WE CAN WORK
TOWARDS DEVELOPING A CURE FOR
VALLEY FEVER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE. SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU- MATTER PRESENT
CENTERS I TO A RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION- TOTALLY
VALLEY FEVER IS A IS A VERY
EVEN AS WE'RE CERTAINLY COVET-
THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING- YOU
CAN SEE AT THE TEMECULA
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO MAKING
NOTES AS WERE ALSO BATTLING
WILDFIRES IN DEALING WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT. I AM A
CHANGES ACTUALLY EXPANDING THE
REACH OF THESE FUN GUY SO
ACTUALLY MORE MORE OF OUR STATE
ACTIONS CAN BE VULNERABLE TO
THE FUNGUS THAT CAUSES VALLEY
FEVER. SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT OUR STATE CONTINUES TO
PRIORITIZE THIS I KNOW THAT.
WE'VE TAKEN ACTION HERE ON IN
THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE
INCREASED FUNDING FOR BOTH
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ALSO OTHER
MEASURES TO COMBAT VALLEY
FEVER. AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE-
AUTHOR AND- IT SENATOR- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS UP BILL
FOR. THIS RESOLUTION FOR THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR HER TOTAL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE. MEMBERS
AS A SERVICE REQUEST FOR MY
BOAT. MEMBERS THIS. THIS
RESOLUTION IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. C. NINE
ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
SIXTEEN. SENATOR CORTESE. HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES CERTEZA DEPARTURES
THE MINIMUM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. SEVEN THREE
INTRODUCTION OF A BILL THAT
PASSED HANDILY OFF THIS WORLD
LAST YEAR- BUT WAS VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR THE BILL BEFORE US
ADDRESSES A VETO MESSAGE
REMOVES PPOSITION AND ADD
SUPPORTERS. A. B. SEVEN WAS A
PRIVATE ANIMAL SUPPORT THE
RESPONSE TO NINE ONE ONE CALLS
TO REQUEST MORE BREAKTHROUGH
BODY PROTECTION GEAR OF THE
CHOOSE TO. EVERY NINE ONE ONE
CALL ME INTO YOUR PERM
PARAMEDIC RESPONSE TO ITS
POTENTIAL TO BECOME A DANGEROUS
SITUATION I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR RIVAL. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I FACE NO BACKER I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI HI CORTESE
I DALLY. NO DOT HI TORONTO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
HIGH GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I WAS
SO I HER TADO. HI JONES NO
KAMMERER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MON I MEAN WHY ARE. I
MELINDA'S NO MEN FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TROUBLE OKAY NO
PAN. HI PORTS AND TINA. I
BROUGHT. FIVE RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER FIVE
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
STERN WELL. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY FOUR.
AFTER WHICH WE GO TO ONE THIRTY
SEVEN AND ONE THIRTY NINE
SENATOR REID ARE YOU PREPARED
ON ONE THIRTY FOUR HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AN ACT
RELATING TO DESERT CONSERVATION
CENTER OFF THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
BILL CREATES THE CALIFORNIA
DESERT CONSERVATION PROGRAM AT
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD. TO ENSURE OUR DESSERTS
ARE PRESERVED FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS BY ENCOURAGING
CRITICAL CONSERVATION
RECREATION AND RESTORATION
PROJECTS THE PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR PROJECTS IN
THE CALIFORNIA DESERT TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE PROTECT AND RESTORE
DESERT HABITAT. AND SACRED
ANCESTRAL LANDS OF LOCAL NATIVE
PEOPLES PROVIDE PUBLIC ACCESS
TO RECREATIONAL AMENITIES AND
REDUCE THE THREATS OF WILDFIRE
DROUGHT FLOOD AND OTHER
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ADKINS I FACE. BACKER GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD I HAVE AI ERA I
PROTESTING. I DALLY. DOT HI
THERE ALSO I EXAMINED EYE LASER
EYE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO
HI JONES NO KIM AUGER FIVE
WHERE I LIVE I THE MON. FIVE
MAGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO  TURBO NO
PAM I FOURTEEN TINA. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. I AMBERG I Y.
CASKEY I WINNER I WELK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES.
BACKER I PORGES. DALLY NO GROVE.
NO MELINDA'S. STERN WELL. HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR RUBIO
SHE'S PREPARED. PLEASE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AN ACT
RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH.
SENATOR RUBIO THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AT THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
WHICH HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO NO VOTES. THIS
BILL WILL ESTABLISH A FULL TIME
STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF CRISIS
SERVICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
DEVELOP EFFECTIVE CRISIS CARE
SYSTEM THAT SAVES LIVES AND
RESOURCES ONE IN SIX
CALIFORNIANS NOW LIVE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND A
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED CRISIS
NETWORK. AS A FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE IN GETTING THESE
CALIFORNIANS THE HELP THEY NEED
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AND I FELT CERTAIN IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I BASE
I BACKER. HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD
I HAVE ITEM ARE YOU PROTESTING
HI DOLLY I DON. I DRAW SO I
EXAMINED EYE LASER FIVE
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. I HURTS
BERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO HI
JONES. CAMCORDER I LAYERED I
LIVE THAT I THE MON FIVE
MAGUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON I A CHILL UP
BOTH I PAN. FIVE FOURTEEN TINA.
I BROUGHT HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG I Y. CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. PORCHES I JONES.
STERN WELL. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM ONE ONE THIRTY NINE
SENATOR LEE MORAN IS READY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WICKS AN ACT RELATING TO
CONSUMER DATA. CENTER LIMB ON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. BUT MEMBERS.
MANY CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE WITH
BURNING OF EXCESS DEBT WHICH
LEAD SOME CONSUMERS TO SEEK OUT
VARIOUS FORMS OF DEBT RELIEF AB
FORTINO FIVE ESTABLISHES
BASELINE REQUIREMENTS SO THAT
CONSUMERS ARE PROVIDED WITH
INFORMATION UP FRONT BEFORE
SIGNING A DEBT SETTLEMENT
CONTRACT AND PERIODIC UPDATES
THROUGHOUT THE CONTACT TO
MONITOR PROGRESS OF THEIR DEBT
SETTLEMENT PLAN. THE AUTHOR HAS
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS WHEN THE
BILL CAME TO THE BANKING
COMMITTEE THERE WERE SEVERAL
INDUSTRY GROUPS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BUT WORKING THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS WE WERE ABLE
TO ARRIVE AT A MUTUALLY
AGREEABLE RESULTS. AS
CALIFORNIA PUSHES THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC AND WORKS TOWARDS AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WE CANNOT
LEAVE CONSUMERS BEHIND THIS
HELP THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT VULNERABLE CONSUMERS ARE
TREATED FAIRLY IF THEY DECIDE
TO INTERACT WITH DEBT-SETTLEMENT COMPANIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IRA.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
THEN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. BASED NO
BACKER. I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I PROTESTING I
DALLY. I DON I TORONTO I
EXAMINED EYE LASER I
CONSOLIDATES I GROW. HERTZBERG
HI I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA HI THE MON. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO TROUBLE BOTH HI PAM
I PERSONS YOU KNOW. HI RALPH I
RUBIO I SKINNER FIVE STERN.
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. FOR JUST NOW PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. ATKINS
GROVE. NO STERN WELL. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FOLLOWING IT NUMBER
ONE FORTY ONE SENATOR AMBER IS
PREPARED. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AN ACT
RELATING TO CLAIMS AGAINST
PUBLIC ENTITIES. SENATOR AMBER
YOU YOU ARE A- I AM UP THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS AT FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE
EXTENDS THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR VICTIMS WERE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. EXTENDS
IT TEN YEARS AFTER THE DATE OF
JUDGMENT IN THE CRIMINAL CASE
FOR THE CRIME OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
ORIGINAL VOTE. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEMS. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE SAME MAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS BASED.
BACKER HI FORGES HI BRADFORD.
HI BY ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY.
DOT I THEY'RE AWESOME HI ADNAN
I GLAZER. I CONSOLIDATE HI
GROSS. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI
HER TADO HI JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE HI I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO- TROUBLE
OKAY. HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO.
HI ROB I RUBIO. I SCANNER. HI
STERN I'M BURKE HI HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER. I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BAYTEX. DALLY GROVE.
JONES MELINDA'S. STERN WELL.
FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY TWO
CENTER LIVE IT'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AN
ACT RELATING TO HIGHER
EDUCATION LABOR RELATIONS.
CENTER LABOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE 2% AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY WHICH PROTECTS
FACULTY BARGAINING RIGHTS BY
ALLOWING FACULTY WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE BARGAINING
UNIT. TO REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR
UNION REPRESENTATION IF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MOVES
THOSE FACULTY POSITIONS TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. THREE YEARS
AGO THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
REQUESTED THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS
MOVE SIX PART TIME FACULTY JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS FOR LECTURERS
ACTIVELY COVERED BY COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT. INTO THE
AFTERNOON INTO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THE SIX PART TIME
POSITIONS WERE ACTIVELY COVERED
BY A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT PRIOR TO THE MOVE BUT
LOST TO GAIN REPRESENTATION
WILL MOVE TO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THAT ACTION SO THE
DENTURE DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
THAT COULD RESULT IN WORKERS
LOSING THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATION SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE UC DECIDES TO MOVE FACULTY
JOB TITLES TO THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. SIX JOB CLASSIFICATIONS
HAVE ALREADY LOST UNION
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE OF A
LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW. MEMBERS
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY IS NEEDED
TO PROTECT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING OF UC FACULTY MOVING
FORWARD. MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I.
PHONE. FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I HAD CANS BASE NO
BACKER HI FORTUS KNOWN BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM HI HI COURTESY
HI DALLY. NO DOG NO TORONTO I
EGGMAN I BELIEVE HER NO
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG. IF I DROVE NO. WHAT
I FOUND. HI HER TADO HI JONES
NOPE CAN'T LONGER I LAYERED
FIVE LLEVA I LIVE ALONE.
MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO THE TROUBLE
NOPE PAM I FORTUNE TINO I
BROUGHT. RUBIO SKINNER I STERN
NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW SKI. I
WINNER I WILL KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN ATKINS.
LIMONEIRA HI NEWMAN. RALPH I
RUBIO HI STERN. FIVE TWENTY
FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE-PASSES I WOULD CHOOSE ME SYDNEY
SEES ME WHEN WE NEED TO MOVE
THE CALL ON THAT ONE MY
APOLOGIES MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
THREE SENATOR AMBER HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
SENATE PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF
LAST YEAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
WORKED ON A PROVISION THAT
PROVIDED FOR. EVERY ELIGIBLE
REGISTERED ACTIVE VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE A BALLOT IN
THE MAIL WHICH THEY COULD
RETURN IN THE MAIL THE ELECTION
WAS INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL IN
TERMS OF VOTER TURNOUT AND
VOTER ACCESS FACT WE HAD THE
HIGHEST VOTER TURNOUT SINCE.
HARRY TRUMAN WAS PRESIDENT.
THIS BILL AT THIRTY SEVEN MAKES
THAT POLICY PERMANENT BEYOND
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE- IT
ALSO DID IT JUST FOR THE-
REQUIREMENTS FOR COUNTIES UNDER
THIRTY THOUSAND IN TERMS OF
THEIR- REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE-
LOCATIONS FOR DROP BOXES I URGE
AND I VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTER GROVE. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY
SEVEN THE PRACTICE OF
AUTOMATICALLY SENDING OUT
BALLOTS IN AN ELECTION OF AN
ELECTION TO EVERY CALIFORNIAN
FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FORWARD WITH WILL
WITHOUT A DOUBT RESULTED MORE
DISTRESSED IN THE VOTING
PROCESS. ALEX WILL BE SENT TO
EVERY CALIFORNIAN BASED ON- AND
MAINTAIN VOTER ROLL SIMILAR TO
THE EDT DEBACLE THAT WE HAVE
GOING ON WHERE- EDT
NOTIFICATIONS ARE SENT TO YOU
KNOW HUNDREDS TO EACH HOUSEHOLD
WE HAVEN'T UPDATED OUR VOTER
ROLLS IN DECADES. WE HAVE A
PURGE VOTER ROLLS IN DECADES WE
CONSTANTLY ASKED FOR. A
EXEMPTION FROM THE FEDERAL
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO UPDATE
OUR VOTER ROLLS HAND- THIS.
PARTICULAR BILL WILL CREATE
DISTRESSED- IN THE VOTING
PROCESS. THESE VOTER ROLLS ARE
ALREADY A MESS FROM THE DMV'S
PRACTICE OF AUTOMATICALLY
REGISTERING CALIFORNIANS TO
VOTE CREATING A CATCH ALL
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS IN ELIGIBLE
VOTERS TO PARTICIPATE. SENDING
UNSOLICITED BALLOTS WILL CREATE
AN INFLUX IN THE NUMBER OF
BALLOTS MULTIPLE BALLOTS WILL
INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FRAUD AND UNDERMINE THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION. THAT COMES AT A
TIME WHEN A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF VOTERS ALREADY HAVE LOST
THEIR CONFIDENCE IN THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS. I CAN TELL
YOU STORY AFTER STORY THAT CAME
INTO MY DISTRICT AND IF YOU
GUYS WERE HONEST ABOUT THE
SUBJECT MATTER YOU WOULD KNOW
THAT. THEY CAME INTO YOUR
DISTRICTS AS WELL BECAUSE I'M
I'M VERY CONFIDENT IT'S NOT
JUST HAPPENING IN KERN AND
TULARE COUNTIES. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
FOURTEEN GOT BACK OF BALLOTS
AND MAIL TO THEIR HOUSE I CAN
TELL YOU AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW BECAUSE HE SHOULDN'T EVEN
BE ON THE DMV ROLLS. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT SEVERAL PEOPLE GOT
BALLOTS IN SEVERAL NAMES- USING
FIRST AND LAST NAME FIRST
MIDDLE AND LAST NAME FIRST NAME
MIDDLE INITIAL AND LAST NAME.
SO I JUST THINK MAKING THIS
PROCESS A- A FUR EVER PROCESS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES
UNDERMINE THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY THAT WE HAVING
CREATES. A MECHANISM AND TO
ALLOW FRAUD A FRAUD TO BE
EXPANDED AND- WE SHOULD HAVE
SOME RAUD MECHANISMS IN PLACE
BEFORE WE MAKE THIS LAW
PERMANENT THANK YOU. RATHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I THINK THAT THE-
THAT THE ONLY REASON THAT THERE
IS DISTRUSTS BY ANYONE IN OUR
VOTING SYSTEM IS BECAUSE OF THE
UNFOUNDED FALSE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THAT ARE BEING SPREAD
ON SOCIAL MEDIA- ON FOX NEWS-
AND OTHER- RIGHT WING OUTLETS
THAT ARE INTENTIONALLY
SPREADING FALSE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES TO TRY TO UNDERMINE
TRUST IN OUR ELECTORAL SYSTEM
ON OUR ELECTION SYSTEM. THAT'S
THE ONLY REASON THERE'S
DISTRUST. EXPANDING THE ABILITY
TO VOTE WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
DOING TODAY THAT DOES NOT-
REDUCE TRUST OF COURSE IF IT'S
DISTORTED INTO A CONSPIRACY
THEORY BY FOX NEWS AT ALL- THE
INDICTMENT AFFILIATION CAN
REDUCE TRUST BUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE TODAY. IS TRYING TO
EXPAND THE AND MAKE IT EASIER.
FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE WE'RE DOING
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN PLACES LIKE TEXAS.
AND GEORGIA. AND SOME OF THESE%
OTHER STATES THAT ARE TRYING TO
MAKE A REALLY REALLY REALLY
HARD. FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE AND
PARTICULARLY TO MAKE IT HARD
FOR CITY DWELLERS FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE FOR
STUDENTS TRYING TO MAKE IT HARD
FOR THEM TO VOTE IN ORDER TO
MANIPULATE THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION. WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
LET'S HAVE EVERYONE GO LET'S
SEND IT TO REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS AND SENIORS AND
STUDENTS AND PEOPLE OF EVERY
RACE SOME BACKGROUND IT SAYS
MAKE AN EQUAL PLAYING FIELD
EVERYONE GETS A BALLOT. INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO SHUT DOWN THE
PROCESS TO MANIPULATE AND TO
UNFAIRLY. INFLUENCE THE RESULT
WHAT TEXAS IN GEORGIA DURING
DOTS WHAT UNDERMINES FAITH IN
THE VOTING PROCESS THIS
INCREASES FAITH IN THE VOTING
PROCESS AND I ALSO FEAR I'VE-
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTERED DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST WANT TO SAY. I'M
GONNA PUT OUT SOME AND MAYBE
SOME OF THE ACTOR CESAR I DON'T
WATCH FOX NEWS. BUT I READ THE
LA TIMES ONCE IN A WHILE AND
THERE WAS JUST RECENTLY. A
GENTLEMAN. PULLED OVER WHO HAD
METHAMPHETAMINES AN ASSAULT
RIFLE. AND A HOST BOXES FULL OF
BALLOTS IN THIS ELECTION SO WE
HAVE SOME PROBLEMS THIS IS THE
FACE THAT WE HAVE SOME PROBLEMS
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO. TRACK
AND FIGURE OUT A BETTER WAY
THAN WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S WHY THERE'S
DISTRUST IN THE PROCESS.
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
I ALSO WANT TO BE HONEST ELSE
WAS REQUESTED BY THE SENATOR
FROM BAKERSFIELD AND JUST SAY
THAT WE DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
CALLS IN MY OFFICE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN EITHER MY
DISTRICT OFFICES FROM ANYONE
SAYING THAT THERE WERE ANY
APPROPRIATE THING INAPPROPRIATE
THINGS HAPPENING WITH BALLOTS
WE DO HEAR FROM PEOPLE IS WITH
THE CENTER FROM SECOND- FROM
SAN FRANCISCO SAID. ACCESS THIS
THIS IS REALLY A PARTISAN ISSUE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO A
VOTE REPUBLICANS DON'T THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
THAT THEY WANT TO VOTE HAVE
ACCESS TO VOTE SO REALLY THIS
IS A VERY PARTISAN ISSUE I LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING ON THIS BILL
VOTING HI AND WE DO HAVE A
PROBLEM AND WE DO NEED TO FIX
IT IT'S ABOUT MISINFORMATION
IT'S ABOUT DISTRUST BUT IT'S
NOT BEING CREATED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR BATES.
PRESIDENT I AM A REPUBLICAN AND
I WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
BUILDS FOOD TO CALL THIS A
PARTISAN ISSUE- AND
GENERALIZATION- THE NARRATIVE
IS CONTINUALLY GENERALIZED TO
OUR PARTY AND I TAKE OFFENSE AT
THAT ALL I WALKED FIVE THOUSAND
PRECINCTS WITHOUT FOLKS IN A
NONPARTISAN ELECTION TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYBODY VOTED SOME OF
THEM ARE NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR
ME AND MADE IT VERY CLEAR BUT I
SAID IT'S STILL IMPORTANT TO
VOTE AND MAKE YOUR VOICE HEARD
I BELIEVE THAT SOMETHING THAT
THOSE OF US WHO SUPPORT THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE BILL OF
RIGHTS. I FEEL VERY VERY-
COMPASSIONATE ABOUT WE CAN UNDO
THE DISTRUST IF WE START BY
TAKING A NONPARTISAN VIEW OF
THE EVANGELICAL ANTIDOTE FULL
STORIES OF OUR REPORTS THAT ARE
COMING IN AND REQUIRE OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE IN OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO TAKE A
DEEPER DIVE INTO THOSE ACTS ARE
ALLEGATIONS ARE MY OFFICE WAS
OVERWHELMED DURING THE DMV
MOTOR VOTER WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
MISS REGISTERED. AS REPUBLICANS
WHEN THEY WANTED TO BE
DEMOCRATS DID WE NOT REPORT
THAT YOU BET YOUR BOTTOM WE
REPORTED IT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
RIGHT AND WE HAD PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVED TWO BALLOTS ARE DID WE
REPORT THAT YOU BET YOUR BOTTOM
WE DID FOR THE TWO ACCUSED US
OF BEING THE ONES THAT HAVE
CREATED THIS FALSE NARRATIVE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY MANY
STORIES ACROSS THIS NATION THAT
VALIDATE THAT THERE'S A LACK OF
TRUST BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
EXPERIENCED THESE VERY THINGS
SO I CALL ON ATTORNEY GENERAL I
CALL ON OUR SECRETARY OF STATE
AND I CALL ON THIS BODY. THE
STOP PROPAGATING THE FALSE
NARRATIVE LET'S GET DOWN TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS THEIR
RIGHTS ARE PRESERVED AND IF WE
KEEP TURNING A DELPHI OUR IDEA
OF FEAR IN A BLIND GUY JUST
BECAUSE FOX NEWS- SOMETHING
THAT'S WRONG WE ARE ALL
INTELLIGENT. EDUCATED AND WE
KNOW WE IT GET HERE WITHOUT
BEING OF THE P. BY THE PEOPLE
IN FOR THE P. WHICH IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND THAT'S WHAT I INTEND TO DO
THANK YOU. CENTERMAN. I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY STUDIES INCLUDING BY
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS. AND
NATIONAL LEVEL TO STATE LEVEL
AND THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
THERE'S BEEN ANY ELECTION
FRAUD- OR OR ANYTHING OTHER
THAN MINUTE DIMINISHED ALEXION
FRAUD WHEN IT COMES TO-
INDIVIDUAL VOTER FRAUD. THE
MAJOR THREATS TO ELECTION
SECURITY COME FROM HACKING
CYBER SECURITY AT ALL. AND I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL- OUR REPUBLICAN
COUNTERPARTS HAVE CONSISTENTLY
BLOCKED EFFORTS TO TRY TO.
INCREASE FUNDING FOR ELECTION
SECURITY CYBERSECURITY ALIKE
WHILE FOCUSING ON THESE VERY
RANDOM. CASES THERE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
SOMETHING LIKE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION VOTERS HI THAT MEANS
INEVITABLY YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
OCCASIONAL MISTAKES BUT THE
IDEA THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW
SYSTEMIC. ARE YOU CAN TAKE
ISOLATED INCIDENTS AND TRY TO
PORTRAY THEM INTO NARRATIVE AND
I THINK THAT IS ALL ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SPOKEN BEFORE. THERE IS A
DELIBERATE ATTEMPT RIGHT NOW TO
TRY TO PAINT A NARRATIVE THAT
THERE IS SYSTEMIC ELECTION
FRAUD HAPPENING. AND I THINK
THIS IS COMPLETELY LUDICROUS
IT'S BEEN DEBUNKED BY EVERYONE
INCLUDING BY REPUBLICANS HAVE
GONE UP AND TRY TO FIND
EVIDENCE OF ELECTION FRAUD. THE
MAJOR THREAT TO OUR ELECTION
SECURITY AGAIN IS CYBER
SECURITY IT'S NOT FROM THESE
EXCESS BALLOTS PAPER BALLOTS IN
THE LIKE AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EYE BUT THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE. AT A TIME
WHEN TOO MANY STATES ARE TRYING
TO LIMIT OUR FRANCHISE OUR
HEARD EARNED RIGHT TO VOTE
WHETHER IT'S FOR WOMEN OR
MINORITIES OR FOR MANY OF US
WHO'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO VOTE
FOR A FEW GENERATIONS. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE EMPHASIZE
THAT IN A DEMOCRACY THE RIGHT
TO VOTE IS AT THE HEART OF THAT
AND WE THIS IS A BILL THAT THAT
FURTHERS THAT CAUSE SO AGAIN I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. SENATOR
BURGESS I. REALLY WASN'T
PLANNING THANK YOU NINE PRESENT
WAS A PLAN AND TALKING ABOUT
THIS. I THINK THERE'S THERE
THERE ARE SOME IMPORTANT POINTS
THAT BOTH. SIDES HAVE MADE ON
THIS ISSUE- LAST WEEK I
RECEIVED TWO BALLOTS. IN THE
RECALL. AND I'M CERTAIN I'M NOT
ALONE ONE WENT TO MY PRIMARY
ADDRESS AND I FILLED OUT AND
MAILED IT IN AND THEN ANOTHER
CAME A COUPLE DAYS LATER TO- MY
IN LAWS HOUSE. NOW I AM NOT OF
THE OPINION THAT. THERE IS A
SYSTEMIC EFFORT IN MY HOME
COUNTY TO UNDO ELECTIONS- IN A
AT A MASS SCALE THAT CAN CHANGE
THE OUTCOME OF AN ELECTION BUT
I THINK IT WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT- INTO THE POINT MADE
EARLIER BY MY COLLEAGUE- FROM.
IRVINE AND ONE EARLIER BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD. IS
THAT IT'S INCUMBENT ON US TO
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL OFFICIALS.
ARE STATE OFFICIALS. TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT PEOPLE. HAVE
GREATER TRUST IN OUR VOTING
PROCESS WORKS SO IF I'M GETTING
TWO BALLOTS- I KNOW THAT OTHERS
ARE ARE GETTING MULTIPLE
BALLOTS AS WELL THAT FEEDS INTO
THIS NARRATIVE. OF DISTRUST. SO
MAKING CERTAIN THAT WE CLEAN UP
THE VOTER ROLLS IN A WAY THAT
ALSO CAN BE PUT OUT THERE INTO
THE PUBLIC DOMAIN THAT THEY ARE
IN FACT. CLEAN AND MORE UP TO
DATE WOULD BE TERRIBLY HELPFUL.
SENATOR MELINDA IS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. R. I WOULD BE
SURPRISED IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY WHO HAVE NOT
RECEIVED PHONE CALLS OR EMAILS
FROM THEIR CONSTITUENTS SAYING
THAT. THEY OR SOMEONE THEY KNOW
RECEIVED MORE THAN ONE BALLOT
OR THEY OR SOMEONE THEY KNOW
RECEIVE DEVELOPER SOMEONE WHO
IS DECEASED- THIS HAPPENS ALL
THE TIME AND I GET THESE TYPES
OF COMMENTS FROM DEMOCRATS AS
WELL AS REPUBLICANS IN MY
DISTRICT WHO HAVE CONCERNS.
WITH BALLOT INTEGRITY THIS IS.
IT'S MORE THAN A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTING TO HEAR ANYBODY
ON THIS FLOOR STAND UP AND SAY
THAT THIS IS A PARTISAN ISSUE.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT IT IS AN
ISSUE OF SIFT SYSTEMIC
MISTRUST. OF THE SYSTEM THAT
HAS BEEN PUT IN PLACE AND THAT
HAS DEGRADED TO A POINT WHERE
PEOPLE DON'T FEEL. THAT THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING THE WAY IT IS
SUPPOSED TO- I DON'T KNOW WHY
ANYBODY WOULD BE OPPOSED TO
MAKING SURE THAT THE VOTER
ROLLS. ARE CLEAN THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE DECEASED OR NOT GETTING
BALLOTS SICK PEOPLE. WHO DO GET
A BALLAD DON'T GET ANOTHER ONE
A FEW DAYS LATER THIS IS COMMON
SENSE EVERYONE SHOULD BE FOR
THESE TYPES OF MEASURES TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS
WORKING. THE WAY IT IS INTENDED
SO IT'S NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
DESPITE SOME THE TRY TO MAKE IT
INTO THAT- AND I WOULD- JUST
ASK YOU MAYBE PERHAPS. GO BACK
THROUGH THE EMAILS THAT YOU
RECEIVED OUR CHECK YOUR VOICE
MAILS BECAUSE I SUSPECT HE WILL
FIND PEOPLE OF YOUR DISTRICT TO
HAVE SIMILAR COMPLAINTS THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR UMBERG YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST TO RESPOND TO A
FEW POINTS NUMBER ONE IN TERMS
OF THE BALLOTS YOU CAN'T VOTE
TWICE YOU'VE GOT A BALANCE WITH
THE BAR CODE. WHEN YOU REGISTER
TO VOTE. YOU REGISTERED THAT
BALLOT THEN. IS SENT TO THE
REGISTERED ADDRESS WITH THE BAR
CODE IT COMES BACK WITH THE BAR
CODE OF ANOTHER BALLOT COMES
BACK WITH A SIMILAR BARCODE.
THEN THOSE BALLOTS ARE PULLED
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO IS THAT
WITH RESPECT TO. ALLEGATIONS OR
REPORTS OF FOLKS RECEIVING
MULTIPLE BALLOTS I HOPE YOU
CALL YOUR REGISTRAR I HOPE YOU
CALL YOUR REGISTRAR AND SAY HEY
THERE'S AN ISSUE. IF THERE IS
FRAUD I HOPE YOU CALL YOUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND SAY
THERE'S AN ISSUE BUT YOU KNOW
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN AFTER THE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION AFTER
THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION.
THERE ARE VIRTUALLY NO REPORTS
OF FRAUD THAT WERE FOUND TO BE.
ACCURATE VIRTUALLY NONE IN
TERMS OF DISTRUST. IF THERE IS
DISTRUST AND PERHAPS THERE IS
IT IS BECAUSE THAT DISTRUST WAS
SPREAD. FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT. BY WAY OF MANY MANY
DIFFERENT MODALITIES AND SADLY
SADLY THAT'S HIS MONEY IRONIES
THOUGH IS IT IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LEE
SUMMER TALKING ABOUT FRAUD AND
MISUSE OF WE ACTUALLY EVERY
REGISTRAR UPDATES THE VOTER
ROLLS EVERY YEAR BUT ALSO THERE
WERE AT LEAST FOUR DEMOCRATS
THAT WERE. UNHAPPY ABOUT THE
RESULTS IN CALIFORNIA IS YOU'LL
NOTE THE REPORT DEMOCRATS THAT
LOST HOUSE RACES. THAT SEEMS TO
BE A BIT IRONIC IN VIEW OF THE
FACT THAT THAT SOME BELIEVE THE
ELECTION HERE WAS NOT
CONDUCTED. PROPERLY. THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
VOTERS CAN EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT
OF FRANCHISE LOOK AT THE
SITUATION RIGHT NOW WITH THE
FIRES. HOW MUCH BETTER IS IT
THOSE WHO ARE IMPACTED BY THE
FIRES CAN VOTE BY MAIL RATHER
THAN RETURNING TO. THEIR PLACE
OF RESIDENCE. IN ANY EVENT.
COLLEAGUES THIS IS AN EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY ELIGIBLE
REGISTERED ACTIVE CALIFORNIAN.
CAN EXERCISE THEIR FRANCHISE. I
URGE A NO VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS. BASICS NO
BACKER. I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM ARE YOU PROTECTING
FIVE DALLY NO DOG. I TORONTO I
ADMIN I. GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
FIVE GROVE NO HERTZBERG. I WAS
SO ON HI FOR TORONTO I JONES NO
CAMCORDER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MON I MEAN WIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
SHOW OF VOGUE. PAN I FORTUNE
TINO. HI BROUGHT FIVE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG HI I
WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER I WILL.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS FORTUS. I TRIED
BOTH. STERN. FIVE TWENTY NINE
NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
BREAK TO BE ABLE TO HAVE LUNCH
I NEED TO REQUEST THAT ALL
MEMBERS RETURNED TO THE TO
THEIR OFFICE WITH THEIR LUNCH
PLEASE REMEMBER TO KEEP YOUR
DISTANCE AND WE WILL BE BACK IN
SESSION AT ONE PM WE PLAN TO GO
ON TONIGHT TILL ABOUT FIVE
THIRTY OR SIX SO BE PREPARED
FOR THAT THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH WE'LL SEE YOU HERE AT ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE SENATE IS READY
TO RECONVENE FROM OUR- MORNING
MEETING. IF WE CAN WE CAN ALL
OUR- GET PREPARED MEMBERS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS GO THROUGH
THE ROLL CALL ONCE AFTER WHICH
WE WILL PUT THE MATTERS ON CALL
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SOME.
MEMBERS THAT ARE MISSING SO-
WE'LL GO THROUGH IT ONCE AND
THEN WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL AND
YOU CAN CATCH IT THE NEXT TIME
IF YOU DON'T CATCH IT NOW WE'RE
GONNA START MEMBERS. WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE FIFTY FIVE
AFTER WHICH WILL GO TO ONE
FIFTY NINE AND THEN ONE SIXTY
THREE. SO ITEM ONE FIFTY FIVE
SENATOR GONZALEZ SHE IS
PREPARED ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. CENTER GONZALEZ
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB FORTY ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN LORENA
GONZALEZ WHICH WILL SET CLEAR
MINIMUM STANDARDS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S USE OF LESS
LETHAL WEAPONS LIKE RUBBER
BULLETS AND TEAR GAS ON
PROTESTERS. AT FORTY CREATES
MINIMUM STANDARDS THAT TRAINED
OFFICERS MUST FOLLOW IF THERE
IS A DANGEROUS AND LAWFUL
SITUATION THIS BILL ALSO WILL
REQUIRE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
REPORT THEIR USE OF PROJECTILES
AND CHEMICAL AGENTS ON
PROTESTERS INCLUDING DOCUMENTED
INJURIES ON THEIR WEBSITES
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF EACH
INCIDENT. IT'LL ALSO ENSURE
THAT PROJECTILES AND CHEMICAL
AGENTS ARE USED ONLY WHEN
APPROPRIATE AND THAT THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC WHEN THEY'RE
EXERCISING THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT THE OTHERS
OFFICES ALSO WORK ITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND WITH RECENT
AMENDMENTS BUT THE POLICE CHIEF
IN PORAC. OFFICIALLY NEUTRAL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL.
SENATOR NELSON. MATTER LAID
DOWN DIRE NO VOTE. YOU KNOW
THIS IS JUST MORE OF THE
ASSAULT. ON LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND TAKING TE HANDCUFFS OFF
CRIMINAL OFFENDERS. PUTTING
THEM ON OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALSTHIS IS NOT THE
MOST EGREGIOUS OF THE BILLS
THAT WILL DEAL WITH OR HAVE
DEALT WITH BUT IT IS EGREGIOUS.
AND I'M SAYING IT'S ENOUGH. IF
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH CHAOS AND
CRIME ON THE STREETS OF AMERICA
TODAY BECAUSE OF CERTAIN THINGS
LEGISLATE TORS PLURAL AT DUNN
AND VOTED FOR THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY. MAYORS INCLUDE COUNCIL
PEOPLE INCLUDED THE FUNDING.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER ATTEMPT BY
URGE A NO VOTE. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER GONZALEZ
YOU MAY CONCLUDE YES I WANT TO
THANK- THE SENATOR FOR HIS
COMMENTS HOWEVER I WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW THEY'VE BEEN- SERIOUS
INJURIES IN FACT MANY PEOPLE
HAVE LOST AN EYE- DUE TO THESE
PROJECTILES AND FOR THAT REASON
AND MANY MORE I RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I VOTE. PHANTOM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA ATKINS I FACE
NO BACKER I FORTUS NO BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM HI HYPERTENSIVE
I DALLY. NO DODD. THEY'RE
AWESOME I ADMIN I LASER I
CONSOLIDATES I GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HER TADO.
NO JONES NO CAN LONGER. LAYERED
HI LLEVA HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO- CHOKO NO PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS. RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN NUMBER I Y.
KASKY FIVE WINNER. I WILL NO
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA DOT. WEST SO. I CAN
LONGER. RALPH STERN. I CAN.
OKAY. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA GOD CAN
LONGER I RALPH. STERN. FIVE
TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. THEY'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER YEAH.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO- MOVE
MOVE TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
RETURNING THE MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS BUT SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RECONSIDER THE VOTE
ON ITEM ONE OH NINE AP AT TEN
FORTY TWO BY SAMMY JO SARKAR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO-
ALL ITEM NUMBER ONE OH NINE.
SAYING NO OBJECTIONS I. THIRTY
TWO NO ZERO. THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO. A RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED. YEAH SENATOR SKINNER
ARE WE STILL ON MOTIONS OF
WRESTLING WE ARE ACTUALLY-
AFTER REQUESTED THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS FILE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
TWO THE INACTIVE FILE. SO
ORDERED. SENATOR HER TITLE DO
YOU THINK THANK YOU UNDER-
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE ALTAR ASKED THAT
IT BE THREE FIFTY FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY ONE BE MOVED FROM THE
THIRD READING TO BE AN ACTIVE
FILE. SO ORDERED. SENATOR DODD.
THE QUESTION THE AUTHOR- PLEASE
REMOVE AB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
THREE FOUR- FROM THE CONSENT-
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDING-
ANY OBJECTION. SAYING AT NO
OBJECTION I THIRTY NINE. NO I
IF THERE IS AN OBJECTION. OKAY
OKAY HI. HE SAID HE GOT. OKAY
OKAY AT SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AT THE COST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE- REMOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
MINUTES SHORTER SENATOR LEYVA
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM. THREE
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX
FROM SPECIAL CONSENT. I ORDERED.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE UNDER MY
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. CNN
WILL GO BACK TO OUR ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO- PICK UP AGAIN FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY NINE SENATOR PAN
IS READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE AN ACT
RELATING TO GENE SYNTHESIS. ON
FOR YEARS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS I RISE TODAY
PRESENT AT SEVENTY FROM THIS
SUMMER- SOLACE WHICH ADDRESSES
A MAJOR BY A SECURITY CONCERN
WITHIN THE GENE SYNTHESIS
INDUSTRY CERTAINLY TECHNOLOGY
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR GREAT
BENEFITS BUT ALSO THERE ARE
RISKS THAT WE NEED TO BE SURE
WE AMELIORATE. SCIENTISTS HAVE
SHOWN THAT IT'S POSSIBLE TO
RECONSTRUCT VIRUSES LIKE OF A
NINETEEN OR EVEN DISEASES LIKE
EBOLA USING MAIL ORDER DNA THAT
COULD BE PURCHASED THROUGH THE
INTERNET FROM GENE SYNTHESIS
COMPANIES. AB SEVENTY ONE SHIRT
JEANS AND THAT THIS COMPANY'S
OPERATING CALIFORNIA CONDUCTING
SCREENINGS OF THE CUSTOMERS AND
ORDERS TO PREVENT BAD ACTORS
FROM PURCHASING POTENTIALLY-
POTENTIAL BUILDING BLOCKS OF
DEADLY PATHOGENS THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY BOTH THE GENE
SYNTHESIS COMPANIES IN THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY WHO.
RECOGNIZING PARTS OF DRESSING
THIS- BY SECURITY ISSUE
ESPECIALLY ASPIRIN I THOUGHT.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ADKINS. FIVE EIGHT. BACKER
HI ORIGINS HI BRADFORD HI COME
BY OTHER HI CORTESE HI SALLY.
GOD HI THE RUSSELL. HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
BY HERTZ BERG. I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HIGHS JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOUR HI THE MON HI
MAGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN. FIVE
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW A
VOGUE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO I
BROUGHT. I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG HI MIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WELL I. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BASE DALLY.
JONES. MELINDA'S I NIELSEN.
STERN. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY AFTER WHICH WE WILL TAKE
A POINT EIGHTY FOUR AND THEN
ONE NINETY NINE. ONE EIGHTY
SENATOR GLAZER. HE IS READY.
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAZE AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS SENATOR GLAZER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY MEMBER MAZE. SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT ONLY SEVEN
NEW POLITICAL PARTIES OF
QUALIFIED TO PARTICIPATE IN
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS WITH ONLY
ONE QUALIFYING THROUGH THE
PETITION PROCESS THIS BILL
WOULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
SIGNATURES NEEDED ON A PETITION
TO FORM A NEW POLITICAL PARTY
FROM 10% 23% PUTTING CALIFORNIA
IN LINE WITH THE VAST MAJORITY
OF OTHER STATES. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO FREE UP NAMES OF PRIOR
UNSUCCESSFUL. POLITICAL
MOVEMENTS BY ALLOWING A NEW
POLITICAL BODY TO REGISTER WITH
THE NAME. THAT HAS BEEN
ABANDONED FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS. LASTLY THIS BILL
FORMALIZES THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S APPEAL PROCESS WHEN
APPLYING FOR A PARTY NAME
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SINGMAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I HAVE I A
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY. DOT I
DRAW SO I EXAMINED EYE LASER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROSS. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. I HER TADO I JONES
I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA
I THE MON HI WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO- SHOW
BOTH. CAN I FORTUNE TINO. I.
ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG I Y. CASKEY I WINNER I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BABIES FOR JUST. KELLY
GROVE. MELINDA'S BUT SHOW A
BOOK. STERN. FIVE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ONE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR
SENATOR KEN LONGER. SHE IS
READY. PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOHN SAWYER AN
ACT RELATING TO PEACE OFFICERS
SENATOR COM MARKER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AT
FOUR EIGHT THREE A DISTRICT
BILL THAT PROVIDES PEACE
OFFICER STATUS TO CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE CENTER MUSEUM OFFICERS
AT EXPOSITION PARK THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. SIR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS
I BASE. BACKER PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI HI CORTESE
I DALLY I DON. I DRAW SO.
AIKMAN I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I
GROSS. I KURTZ BERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA I THE
MON HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT HI WE CASKEY I WINNER.
I WELL I. FOR NOTE I'D PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. BASE.
TORONTO I STERN. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE NINETY NINE
SENATOR PAN HE'S READY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL IS SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY. AND ACTUALLY IN THE
STATE PROPERTY CENTER PENN FOR
YEARS THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
SENATORS AT RICE PRESENT EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN- FROM SUMMER
RECORDING WHICH IS A DISTRICT
BILL RELATED TO SOON TO BE
SURPLUS PROPERTY IN STUDENT
HOUSING. THIS BILL ADDRESSES
TWO IMPORTANT ISSUES FOR THE
STATE MY DISTRICT INCREASING
COLLEGE ENROLLMENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO UC DAVIS
MET CENTER LOCATE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO- PLANTS EXPANDED
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS IN THE
SACRAMENTO CAMPUS THIS BILL
WOULD TRANSFER A DOJ PROPERTY
NEAR THE CAMPUS. TO UC DAVIS
FOR STUDENT HOUSING WITH THAT
PROPERTY BECOME SURPLUS TO OFF
SITE CENTERS LIKE UC DAVIS
SACRAMENTOCAMPUS ALLOWS A
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES GROWN ROMAN
WITHOUT STUDENTS WITHOUT THE
UNIVERSITY HOUSING STUDENTS
STRUGGLE FIND A PLACE TO LIVE-
SO THIS IS AGAIN IMPORTANT FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO. HELP BUILD
OUT. THAT CAMPUS OR STRICTLY AS
PER NIGHT BUT- IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS
I BASE. BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD. BY ADAM ARE YOU
PROTESTING HI SALLY I DON FIVE
TORONTO. HI EGGMAN. HI GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES I GROSS I HURTS
BERG HI WEST SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MOON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN'S I
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG ALL
RIGHT I WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER.
WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. BATES I. BRADFORD I.
STERN WINNER HI BIASED THIRD
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO OH
SEVEN AFTER WHICH WE WILL TAKE
UP TO TEN TO TWELVE AND TWO
THIRTEEN SENATOR ADMIN IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AN ACT
RELATING TO REAL ESTATE.
SENATOR EDMUND FORGERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS AB NINE FORTY EIGHT
DEALS WITH APPRAISALS YOUR
APPRAISAL OF YOUR HOUSE SHOULD
NOT DEPEND ON THE COLOR OF YOUR
SKIN THIS GOES TO FIX IT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAME MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BASE I BECKER. I PORCHES I
BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM HI I
PROTESTING I DALLY I DONT. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN I. GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROVE. I HURTS
BERG I WAS SO I HER TADO I
JONES NOPE CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
I LLEVA HI THE MOON I ACQUIRED
I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
I FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN. AMBERG
I WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER. I WELL
I THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELINDA'S I STERN. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO TEN SENATOR SKINNER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SOMETHING BILL NINE NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AND ACTIONS RELATING
QUESTIONERS. SENATOR SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS EIGHTY
NINE NINETY WOULD STRENGTHEN
THE VISITING RIGHTS FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
HAVING CLOSE FAMILY CONTACT
IMPROVES THE MENTAL HEALTH THE
BEHAVIOR IN THE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRESS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
JAILED OR INCARCERATED. AND OF
COURSE IT IS VERY BENEFICIAL TO
THEIR FAMILIES OUR OWN RECORD
CDCR RECORDS SHOW THAT THOSE
PRISONERS. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
INCARCERATED WHO HAVE REGULAR
VISITATION. ARE JUST THERE- THE
SITUATION IN DURING THEIR TIME
OF INCARCERATION IS IMPROVED
AND THERE ARE LESS BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES- THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE. ENSURED THAT VIDEO ONLY
JAILS WILL CONTINUE TO CONDUCT
VIDEO ONLY VISITS SO THERE'S
NOT A CONCERN THERE WITH THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. SENATOR NELSON. THE
PRESIDENT LAID DOWN THE SENATE
THERE'S AN ISSUE OF BEING%
IGNORED HERE AND THAT'S
INSTITUTIONAL SECURITY.
INSTITUTIONAL SECURITY NEAREST
TO THE BENEFIT OF THE FREE
STAFF AS WELL AS THE
INCARCERATED. HOW DO YOU THINK
CONTRABAND GETS INTO THESE.
RESIDENTS OUR- YEAH THEY DON'T
DESCEND FROM THE FROM THE
HEAVENS. THEY TRIED TO BRING
THE MEN WITH DRONES. BUT THE
VISITING AS A KEY AREA. AND
THERE'S NO QUALIFICATION HERE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO MAKE DETERMINATIONS BASED ON
INSTITUTIONAL SECURITY. IT'S
JUST A BLANK CHECK YOU WANT TO
COME UP. I THINK WE NEED TO BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT THIS THERE ARE
REASONS FOR THE SECURITY OF THE
INSTITUTIONS. THAT ARE NEAR TH
BENEFIT AGAIN OF NOT JUST THE
FREE STAFF IN THE NH. BUT THE
WHOLE INSTITUTION. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR SKINNER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. ADKINS FIVE BASE NO
BACKER. HI FORGES NOPE BRADFORD
I HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY
NO DOG. I DURAZO I A GIVEN I
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATES FIVE
GROVE NO HERTZBERG I WEST SO I
HER TADO NO JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED. I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE
I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. NO MAN.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH NO PAN. I FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH. HI RUBIO. I SKINNER.
FIVE STERN ON BERG. HI WHAT
CASKEY I WINNER I WELL. NOW
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA I. MAN NO STERN.
PRICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA TEMPORARILY PASS ON ITEM
TWO TRUCKS MOVING ON TO ITEM
TWO THIRTEEN SENATOR AMBER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TELL TEN TWENTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
CENTER UNDER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AB TEN TWENTY
STRENGTHENS STATE FOREST AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE HOSPITAL FAIR
PRICING ACT. BY PROVIDING
PATIENTS WITH MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR BILLS AND HOW TO
APPLY FOR MEDICO FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE EXTENDING
PROTECTIONS AGAINST ADVERSE
CREDIT REPORTING IN THE
COMMENCEMENT OF CIVIL ACTIONS
FROM A HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS AFTER
INITIAL BILLING. AND REQUIRING
DEBT COLLECTORS AND DEBT BUYERS
TO CERTIFY THAT THE PATIENT HAS
BEEN SCREENED FOR PUBLIC
PROGRAMS AND FINANCIAL SYSTEMS
BEFORE FILING A LAWSUIT IT ALSO
RAISES THE INCOME LEVEL FOR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FROM THREE
OR 50% OF THE POVERTY LEVEL
BEFORE HER PERCENT. URGENT HIGH
LEVEL. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEVEN
NINE ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. I ARCHULETA I.
ACTIONS I BASE HI BECKER. I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD HI COME BY
ADAM ARE YOU PROTESTING HI
DALLY I DON. HI THERE AWESOME
HI EXAMINED I BELIEVE HER I
CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH I HURTS
BERG. I WAS SO. I HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I HAVE A TELEPHONE HI
PAM I FOURTEEN TINO. I ROTH I
REVIEW IT SKINNER. HI STERN
NUMBER HI I WAKE OUT SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI PRICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER FILE NUMBER TWO TWO TWO
AFTER WHICH WE WILL TAKE UP TO
TWENTY SEVEN AND TWO THIRTY
EIGHT SENATOR ALAN. HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT SENATOR ALAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT- ON BEHALF
OF- MY SOME MEMBERS OF OUR
BLOOMINGTON PLEASE PRESENT A B.
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WHICH
ESTABLISHES. THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF HATE. TWENTY
TWENTY LAST YEAR ANTI ASIAN
HATE CRIMES SURGED BY A HUNDRED
AND 49% HE CRIMES AGAINST GAY
MEN JUMPED NEARLY 30% TO
SEVENTY CRIMES ANTI TRANSGENDER
HATE CRIMES ROSE ABOUT 26%
WE'VE SEEN DRAMATIC INCREASES
IN HATE CRIMES AGAINST JEWS
AFTERMARKETS AND MANY OTHERS.
ALREADY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE LAPD IS REPORTED A 66%
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES OVERALL
THE 26% INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES. BASED ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION WHILE WE STILL HAVE
SOME DATA ON THE NUMBER AND
TYPE OF HATE CRIMES ARE BEING
PERPETRATED EXPERTS SAY. THAT
THE FBI DATA LIKELY UNDERCOUNTS
THE NUMBER OF HATE CRIMES IN
AMERICA BOTH BECAUSE MOST MANY
VICTIMS DON'T REPORT INCIDENTS.
AND LOCAL AGENCIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPORT A CRIME DATA
TO THE FBI. TO DO THE
STAGGERING STATISTICS ON THE
CHALLENGE OF MONITORING
COLLECTING ANALYZING THIS DATA.
IT'S CLEAR THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS BETTER TOOLS AND
DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS TO HELP
US TRACK. AND REPORT THIS
INFORMATION SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE. BY CREATING
THIS COMMISSION TO MONITOR AND
ASSESS CURRENT TRENDS RELATIVE
TO HATE CRIMES. PRETTY SOON-
REPORTS ON THESE TRENDS MAKE
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR. AND
RELEVANT CITY AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. I RESPECT FOR US
FROM EVER. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE. BACKER HI FOR.
NO BRADFORD I COME BY IT I. HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. DOT I
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HI FURTADO I JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MON. I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
I MEN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO
WHAT SHOW VOGUE I PANNED. HI
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. BABIES NO. DALLY GROVE.
STERN. FIVE THIRTY THREE KNOWS
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
ITEM UP ON OUR AGENDA IS. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
SENATOR GLACIER. SURE WE PASS
ON FILE ON TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
THE SKEWS ME YOU'RE RIGHT WRONG
WRONG PERSON SENATOR PARDON
TINA THAT'S OKAY YOU CAN
COMMUTE YOU CAN CONFUSE ME WITH
OTHER PEOPLE. YES ERA IF YOU
HAD LET ME HAVE IT READ FIRST
AND- THEY WILL MOVE ON TO YOU
SIR SENATOR. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT
RELATING TO FIREARMS NOW
SENATOR FOR DINNER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT A B. ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY A BILL
THAT WOULD JUMPSTART
CALIFORNIA'S OWN CRIME GUN
TRACING PROGRAM. THE CRIME GUN
IS ANY FIREARM THAT IS
ILLEGALLY POSSESSED USED IN A
CRIME OR SUSPECTED TO HAVE BEEN
USED IN A CRIME IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY. THE AUTOMATIC AUTOMATED
FARM SYSTEM APPROXIMATES THAT
75% OF ALL CRIME GUNS
ORIGINATING FROM WITHIN THE
STATE. AND WHILE THE G. D. O.
J. BUREAU OF ALCOHOL TOBACCO
AND FIREARMS AND EXPLOSIVES
COLLECTS DATA ON FIREARMS
ACQUISITION AND REGISTRATION
THEY DO NOT CONDUCT A
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF THE
AVAILABLE DATA. ON SEIZED GUNS
IF WE ARE TO REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE OUR FOCUS MUST BE ON
THE INITIAL SOURCE OF CRIME
GUNS FROM IRRESPONSIBLE DEALERS
WHO PROFIT. OFF THE SALE OF
FIREARMS AND INFILL INFILTRATED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THERE ARE A LOT OF
RESPECTABLE GUN DEALERS IN
CALIFORNIA THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO OWN GUNS IN OUR
STATE OUR LEGAL GUN OWNERS AND
DON'T CREATE A PROBLEM HOWEVER.
A SMALL MINORITY OF DEALERS
SUPPLY THE CRIMINAL MARKET
ABOUT 5% OF GUN DEALERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ABOUT 90% OF
RECOVERED CRIME GUNS
NATIONWIDE. THESE DEALERS
CREATE DANGEROUS CONDITIONS IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
ESPECIALLY IMPACT COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. IN CALIFORNIA THE
EFFECT. I ACCESS TO THE TRAFFIC
FARM AND CAN OF COLOR CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED AFRICAN AMERICAN
MEN WHO MAKE UP LESS THAN 4% OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION. YET
THEY REPRESENT 30% OF GUN
HOMICIDE VICTIMS. AFRICAN
AMERICANS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FOUR PART
EIGHTEEN TIMES AS LIKELY TO BE
MURDERED WITH A GUN AS WHITE
MEN OF THE SAME AGE AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE WILL ADDRESS THE GAP
IN CRIME GUN TRACING. BY
REQUIRING CALIFORNIA DOJ TO
ANALYZE THE CRIME GUN DATA IT
ALREADY HAS A DETERMINE TRENDS
AND PATTERNS RELATED TO HOW
CRIME CRIME GUNS ARE SOLD IN
TRAFFIC. BY PROVIDING ANALYSIS
ON HOW A CRIME GUNS ARE BEING
DIVERTED FROM A LEGAL MARKET
AND IDENTIFYING THE RESPONSIBLE
DEALERS WE CAN PROPERLY ADDRESS
AND ROUTE OUT ONE OF THE CAUSES
OF GUN VIOLENCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- WE
HAVE SEEN TOO MANY GUN VIOLENCE
EPISODES IN THIS STATE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT
THIRTY SEVEN SENATE DISTRICT I
THINK IT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION
TO SAY WE ARE FACING A EPIDEMIC
OF GUN VIOLENCE TODAY AND IT'S
ALL THAT TO BEGIN TO SOLVE THE
CRISIS WE NEED BETTER DATA WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT'S NOT WORKING. HI
THIS IS A REGIONAL BILL- IT
WILL HELP INFORM OUR SOLUTIONS
WILL HELP INFORM US IN THE
LEGISLATURE HI SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. SENATOR NELSON. THERE'S
A GERM OF THE SENATE. THIS BILL
HER. I WOULD ARGUE HAS SOME
MERIT. BUT TO SAY THAT THIS IS
THE PANACEA. IN THE HANDS OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IT IS NOT.
FEDERAL ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN ON ABLE.
NOT WITHSTANDING SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES WE HAVE PROVIDED THEM
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. TO CONFISCATE THE
WEAPONS OF PROVEN FELONS WHO
USE GUNS IN THE COMMISSION OF
THEIR CRIMES IN OR PROVE IT
UPON THEIR RELEASE FROM CIS
INTO SOCIETY TRUMP HAPPEN JUST
GIVE UP THOSE GUNS. I THINK
IT'S AROUND TEN THOUSAND NOW.
AND WE'VE BEEN GIVEN THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
THAT AGENCY DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. THE CONFISCATE THOSE
GUNS. I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO
PROPOSE THAT WE TAKE THAT
AUTHORITY AWAY FROM THE CURRENT
GENERAL AND GIVE IT TO THE
LOCAL SHERIFF'S. WE COULD NOT.
DO ANY WORSE THIS IS ONE WAY.
AND A PATHWAY TO GET GUNS
ABSOLUTELY OUT OF THE HANDS. OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE PROVEN.
THAT THEY WOULD DO HARM AND WHO
ARE KNOWN TO HAVE WEAPONS. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS SIDE OF. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING
NINE SENATOR BURTON KENO YOU
MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT GUN SAFETY CRIME
SAFETY COMMUNITY BASED HELP TO
SOLVE THE VIOLENCE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD PROBLEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE FIVE BECKER HI
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY I DONT.
I TORONTO I EXAMINED EYE LASER.
I CONSOLIDATE I GROSS.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LABOR. HI THE MOON. I REQUIRE
I MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN.
I FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS. I RUBIO
HI SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I Y.
OWSKI I WINNER. I WILL. HI
PLEASE CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS.
PORCHES GROVE. STERN COULD YOU
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AGAIN
FORTUS I. GROVE STERN. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NOTES ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR LEYVA
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSE
THREE OF US AN ACT RELATING TO
PRESCHOOL. SENATOR LEYVA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY
MEMBERS 60% OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER AGE SIX COME
HOME COME FROM HOMES WHERE
ENGLISH IS NOT THEIR PRIMARY
LANGUAGE. IS IMPORTANT TO
IDENTIFY DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
WHEN THEY ENTER PRESCHOOL TO
DESIGN PROGRAMS AND TRAIN
TEACHERS TO SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS AND WAYS TO DEVELOP
THEIR HOME LANGUAGE AND
ENGLISH. RICHARD RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT FLUENCY IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES BENEFITS CHILDREN BY
BROADENING THEIR COGNITIVE
FLEXIBILITY ENHANCING THEIR
LEARNING CAPABILITIES AND
GIVING STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BECOME MULTILINGUAL SO THEY
ARE EVEN MORE COMPETITIVE IN
THE GLOBAL WORK FORCE. A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE TAKES A
CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN
IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLANNED FOR
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE FOR
SUPPORTING TOOL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. SPECIFICALLY THIS
WILL REQUIRES THAT STATE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. TO ESTABLISH A
DEFINITION SPECIFICALLY FOR
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS DEVELOP
A STANDARDIZED PROCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM PROVIDERS. TO IDENTIFY
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO REPORT
REPORT INFORMATION ABOUT DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS TO THE STATE.
EIGHTY THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE AS
A WOMEN'S CAUCUS PARTY BIL AND
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND POLICY COMMITTEES. MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I HAVE
A- IS THERE ANY. OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEVEN NINE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
OKAY ANY OBJECTIONS SAYING.
NINE FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
TWO FORTY THREE. SENATOR DURAZO
HE IS READY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAN AS AN ACT
RELATING TO HUMAN SERVICES
CENTER DRAWS ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER RAY AS
I PRESENT A B. FOURTEEN SIXTY
ONE THIS BILL ENSURES VICTIMS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE CRITICAL
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT
ARE- AVAILABLE TO THEM.
ENSURING IMMIGRANT VICTIMS OF
CRIME RECEIVE SERVICES IN A
TIMELY MANNER IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE THIS BILL CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE IN THE CURRENT LAW SO
WE CAN ALLOW QUALIFIED VICTIMS
OF CRIME TO RECEIVE SERVICES
THIS BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THERE ANY
DISK OR TO ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. NONE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROL. ALAN KAY. HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BABES HI BECKER HI
PORGES HI BRADFORD I KERR BY
OTHER. HI CORTESE I DALLY I DON
I TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. I HURTS
BERG FIVE WESTERN HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I A TELEVOTE HI PAM.
FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
I WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER. I WILL
HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO ITEM TWO FORTY
NINE SENATOR ROB. HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND ACTUALLY NEED
TO HEALING ARTS CENTER A- THANK
YOU BETTER PRESIDENT THIS IS
THE SUNSET GO FOR THE BORDER
VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS THE
BILL CONTAINS SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE BOARD
SUNSET REVIEW. ONE EXTENDS THE
BOARD BY THREE YEARS TO IT
ESTABLISHES A SCHOOL PHASE
THREE AND ESTABLISH A SCHOOL
APPROVAL TIMELINES AND PROCESS
SEES. AND FOUR MAKES OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES REQUESTED BY
THE BOARD DURING THIS REVIEW IN
PREVIOUS REVIEWS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. IS THERE
ANY ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I BAIT I BECKER I FOR JUST
HI BRADFORD I COME BY IT- I
PROTESTING. I DALLY I TODD I
DRAW SO I EXAMINED EYE LASER
EYE CONSOLIDATES I GROSSED FIVE
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN I. OTERO
ABODE I CAN I FORTUNE TINO. I
BROUGHT I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG ALL RIGHT HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER. HI WELL HI.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM TWO FIFTY ONE AFTER WHICH
IS TWO FIFTY TWO TO FIFTY THREE
AND THEN TO SEVENTY SENATOR.
DODD. ON TWO FIFTY ONE. HE'S
READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY AN ACT RELATING TO DRUG
TREATMENT CENTER TO DOT THE
FORAGERS. RICE IS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
HOPE YELLOW AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO IS A PILOT PROGRAM FOR YOLO
COUNTY TO CREATE THE WHOLE PLO
SECURED RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM THE SUNSETS IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IT IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM FOR
INDIVIDUALS BASED ON THE
RECOMMENDATION AND EVALUATIONS
OF TREATMENT PROVIDERS. IT WILL
ALLOW THE COUNTY TO PROVIDE
TEMPORARY CAN FIND DRUG
TREATMENT IN A CLINICAL SETTING
FOR INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
DISORDER. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF A FELONY.
ABOUT TO NOT GO TO JAIL OR
PRISON BUT INSTEAD GET
TREATMENT FOR THEIR ADDICTION
AND HOPEFULLY BE ON THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY. WE KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING.
LOOK AT ANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT GET
ARRESTED. FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CRIMES RELATED TO
THEIR DRUG ADDICTION AND NEVER
GET TREATMENT. MEMBERS THIS
PILOT PROGRAM IS MEANT TO
PROVIDE OTHER ANOTHER OPTION
FOR TREATMENT PROVIDERS IN THE
JAILS AND PRISONS WHICH BY
DEFAULT HAVE BECOME. SUCH
FACILITIES THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN
OVER TWENTY AMENDMENTS TO
ENSURE THE PILOT OFFERS
EVIDENCE BASED RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT AND THAT ALL
TREATMENT IS IN LINE WITH WHAT.
A SAM RECOMMENDS. THAT WOULD BE
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE FOR THOSE OF
USERS ARE NOT AWARE- ONCE A
TREATMENT IS COMPLETED THE
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE FELONY
RECORD RECORD EXPUNGEMENT. THIS
PILOT WILL ALLOW US TO GET IN
FRONT OF THE ISSUE AND NOT WAIT
AROUND FOR MORE LIVES TO GET
RUINED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS HI EIGHT FIVE BECKER
HI FORTUS HI BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY HI TODD
FIVE TORONTO I ADMIN I GLAZER.
I CONSOLIDATE I GROVE. I HURTS
BERG HI WEST SO. HYPER TANTO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA. I THE MON HI MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON I A SHOW OF BOTH I CAN.
HI FOURTEEN TO NO. I. ROSS HI
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER FIVE STERN.
NUMBER HI HI FI CASKEY I WINNER.
WINNER ALL RIGHT WELL. HI BY
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO FIFTY TWO SENATOR AMBER. HE
IS READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
DAILY AN ACT RELATING TO
DISTANCE LEARNING. SENATOR
ROBERT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WERE MADAM
PRESIDENT- EIGHTY FIFTEEN SIXTY
IS A BUILT LEAD TO GREATER
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BY
HELPING MORE STUDENTS GET
ACCESS TO FREE OR LOW COST
INTERNET SERVICES. BILLS AND
JOINT UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT OUR DRIVER. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SIR ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SAYING
NINE ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO FIFTY THREE.
SENATOR ALAN. HE IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT
RELATING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
SENATOR ALLEN THE FOUR YEARS
THANK YOU HAVE A PRESENT MEMBER
SEND THIS BILL REQUIRES OUR OWN
CITIES COUNTIES IN THE CHP TO
POST FINANCIAL DETAILS. ABOUT
POLICE MISCONDUCT SETTLEMENTS
AND JUDGMENTS ON THEIR WEBSITES
INCLUDING HOW MUCH THE
SETTLEMENT PLACE TO PLAINTIFFS.
NOT IN CITIES AND COUNTIES
SPEND TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON
SETTLEMENTS AND JUDGMENTS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT MISCONDUCT AND
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE CASES
WITH. LITTLE TO NO PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE. COMMONLY
MUNICIPALITY SETTLE CLAIMS OUT
OF COURT IN PART TO AVOID
FURTHER SCRUTINY AND ALMOST
ALWAYS INCLUDE CITY COUNCIL. OR
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MEETINGS.
ALL TAXPAYERS FOOT THE BILL FOR
THE SETTLEMENTS THE PUBLIC
OFTEN FINDS OUT ABOUT THEM ONLY
AFTER THEIR INTREPID WORK. DONE
BY JOURNALISTS. INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THESE
MISCONDUCT SETTLEMENTS ARE
DIFFICULT TO FIND MOST DETAILS
ARE REVEALED ONLY AFTER
REPORTERS OR RESIDENTS. FILED A
REQUEST. IN TWO AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN.LA ALICEVILLE SANDALS
ISSUE TO SEVENTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. IN WHAT ARE KNOWN AS
POLICE BRUTALITY BONDS. BY THE
WALL STREET BANKERS WHO PROFIT
OFF THEM. THESE ARE PAID FOR BY
TAXPAYERS THESE ARE LOANS THAT
TAKE YEARS TO PAY OFF DEBT
UNDERWRITING FEES AND HIGH
INTEREST RATES CHARGED BY
INVESTMENT FIRMS. AND AT CITY
OF LA TOOK OUT. NEARLY A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF BONDS.
TO PAY OFF- A POLICE MISCONDUCT
CASES SO. IT ALSO REALLY THIS
IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THE PUBLIC
HAS FULL UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COST NOT JUST OF COURSE. THE
BROKEN LIVES OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VICTIMIZED- YOU KNOW THE POLICE
OFFICERS THEMSELVES WHO WHO ARE
FTEN TIMES- SUFFERED THROUGH
THIS EXPERIENCE BUT THEN ALSO
AND THE TAXPAYERS ARE ARE ARE
PUBLIC PURSE THAT ENDS UP
BEING. REALLY IMPACTED BY BY
CASES OF MISCONDUCT AND
BRUTALITY AND SO. ON THIS BILL
IS RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. SIR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
MAN THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM TWO
SEVENTY. SENATOR LEYVA. SHE IS
READING OFF MADAM SECRETARY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER FOR BATH
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER
LABOR THE FORAGERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT
TWELVE FIFTEEN TAKES NECESSARY
AND COMMON SENSE STEPS TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE UC
ADMISSIONS PROCESS PARTICULARLY
IN ATHLETICS ADMISSIONS WHICH
ARE EXPRESSLY ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO ABUSE.
SPECIFICALLY AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
INSURERS THAT DONATIONS AND
PERSONAL CONNECTIONS ARE NOT
CONSIDERED INADMISSIBLE
MINISTRATION ADMISSION
DECISIONS REQUIRES UC CAMPUSES
TO REPORT ON THEIR ATHLETIC
ADMISSIONS PROTOCOLS AND
OUTCOMES TO PREVENT FRAUD AND
REQUIRES THE UC TO CONDUCT
REGULAR INTERNAL AUDITS OF THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS AT UC
CAMPUSES. THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN VARSITY VARSITY BLUES
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SCANDAL AND
SUBSEQUENT STATE AUDIT OF THESE
DO YOU SEE ADMISSION SYSTEM
SHOW THAT EMISSIONS FRAUD
REMAINS A PREVALENT AND URGENT
ACTION ISSUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. EVEN IN THE MIDST
OF THE PANDEMIC THE UC RECEIVED
RECEIVED A ALL TIME RECORD HIGH
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS FOR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EMISSIONS
ESTIMATED AT NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS. SIMPLY PUT EACH
OF THOSE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND APPLICANTS DESERVES A
FAIR SHOT. FOR EVERY STUDENT
ADMITTED IN EXCHANGE FOR
DONATIONS OR AS A FAVOR TO
FRIENDS OR FAMILY A QUALIFIED
STUDENT LOSES THEIR SPOT. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRE ADMISSION
STAFF TO VERIFY A STUDENT
ATHLETES ATHLETIC ABILITY OR
TALENT PRIOR TO ADMISSION AND
FOLLOW UP AFTER ADMISSION TO
ENSURE STUDENT PARTICIPATION IN
THAT SPORT. BUT THE STATE AUDIT
REVEALD IS THAT MORE
SIGNIFICANT REFORMS ARE NEEDED
TO ADDRESS THE WORST OF THE
ABUSES RELATIVE TO INFLUENCING
ADMISSIONS DECISIONS AS WELL AS
DEAL WITH INCONSISTENT AND
UNFAIR ADMISSIONS PROCESSES.
OVER ALL MEMBERS A. B. TWELVE
FIFTEEN WILL INCREASE OVER SO
AND- TO PREVENT PREVENT FRAUD
IN THE UC'S ADMISSIONS SYSTEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ENVELOPE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NONE THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THERE IS AN
OBJECTION SO WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI. I
BASE HI BACKER HI OR JUST HI
BRADFORD. COME BY I CORTESE I
DALLY FIVE DOT FIVE THEY'RE
AWESOME HI EXAMINED EYE LASER.
GONZALEZ I DROVE. FIVE HURTS
BERG FIVE WEST SO. I HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S HI MAN I. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I- CHILLAGOE. HI PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE STERNE
AMBERG HI I WAKE COUNTY I
WINNER. I WILL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD I.
GLAZER STERN. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW
TO ITEM. ONE SIXTY THREE ONE
SIXTY THREE SENATOR CATALOGUER.
SHE IS READY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR CAM
WALKER AND ACTION RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE SENATOR
KAMMERER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
ONE TWO FOUR. JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS IT IS A LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL.
THE ACLU ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY
60% FEMALE STATE PRISONERS
NATIONWIDE AND AS MANY AS 94%
OF CERTAIN FEMALE PRISON
POPULATIONS HAVE EXPERIENCED
PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL ABUSE.
BEFORE BEING INCARCERATED WE
KNOW THAT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
AND INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
AND OTHER SEVERE FORMS OF
TRAUMA ARE MORE LIKELY TO LAND
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
YEAH OUR STATE'S CURRENT LEGAL
FRAMEWORK LACKS CLEAR
MECHANISMS TO CONSIDER RELEVANT
FACTORS AND EXPERIENCES THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO THE COMMISSION
OF THAT OFFENCE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE SOCIETAL TRAUMA CROP
CAUSED BY CRIMINALIZING THESE
INDIVIDUALS SPANS GENERATIONS.
EIGHTY ONE TO FOUR ADDRESSES
GAPS AND FAILURES OF THE
CURRENT LEGAL SYSTEM BY
ALLOWING. NOT MANDATING
ALLOWING THE COURT TO CONSIDER
AT VARYING STAGES OF SENTENCING
AND RESENTENCING. HOW THE
DEFENDANT'S OWN TRAUMA
CONTRIBUTED TO THE COMMISSION
OF THE OFFENSE AND OR
CONVICTION. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN AN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE STRUCK PROVISIONS
RELATED TO CONSECUTIVE
SENTENCES AND SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS. EXCLUDING THE
VIOLENT PANEL FELONIES FROM A
CORE RELIEF ANTI AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE AND LIMIT THE MANDATE
ON IMPOSING THE LOWER TERM AT
SENTENCING TO WIN THE
AGGRAVATING CIRCUMSTANCES
OUTWEIGH THE MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES. EIGHTY ONE TO
FOUR WOULD SUPPORT MANY
SURVIVORS MOSTLY WOMEN FEMALE
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENCE SEXUAL
VIOLENCE INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
BY REQUIRING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO CONSIDER THE
FULL CONTEXT OF RELEVANT
FACTORS OF A PERSON'S
CIRCUMSTANCES AND EXPERIENCES
THROUGHOUT THE COURT PROCESS.
EIGHTY ONE TWO FOUR IS NOW A
MUCH MORE MODEST VERSION OF ITS
ORIGINAL FORM AND WILL GIVE
MANY SURVIVORS A MECHANISM TO
SEEK JUSTICE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. LITTLE. MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS FIVE BASE. BACKER HI FOR
DRESS NO BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI COURTESY HI DOLLY. DOT
I- ALSO I EXAMINED EYE LASER I
CONSOLIDATE OUR GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I. LEIVA I THE MON. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN.
NIELSEN NO ULTRABOOK. PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO. I ROSS FIVE RUBIO
HI SKINNER FIVE STERNE AMBERG
HI MIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I
WILL KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE OB
TO MEMBERS. FAITH NO. DALLY NO.
GROVE NO HER TADO. NEWMAN
TELEVOTE. STERN. FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT WHO KNOWS EIGHT. I'M
SORRY OKAY. THE MOVE THE CAR IN
CENTER CAMP KAMMERER ASKED THAT
WE MOVE THE CALL.
TAKING A
LITTLE BREATHER HERE. MEMBERS
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THIS WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER ONE
OH EIGHT. MEMBERS WERE GONNA I
LEFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER. ONE SIXTY THREE. WE
HAVE LIFTED THE CALL ICE TWENTY
EIGHT. HE KNOWS EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES SENATOR CALMER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON AB ONE TWO
FOUR. YOU COULD IS THERE
OBJECTION TO SEEING NINE WE CAN
SAY RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED
BY THIRTY NINE NO ZERO. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
ONE OH EIGHT AFTER WHICH WILL
TAKE UP ONE TWENTY FIVE. ONE
FORTY NINE AND ONE THIRTEEN.
ONE OH EIGHT. SENATOR DURAZO.
SHE IS READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO
AN ACT RELATING TO HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS SENATOR DRAWS SO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MAN
PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO
THIS BILL WILL STRENGTHEN LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION AGAINST LOCAL THREATS TO
THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND SAFETY
INCLUDING THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT A
FACILITY OR A PORTION OF A
FACILITY. TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS OF
CAUSE AND EXPOSURE IN
CALIFORNIA MULTIPLE REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES HAVE JURISDICTION
OVER BUSINESSES THAT HANDLE OR
GENERATE HAZARDOUS WASTE
MATERIALS THAT POSE A RISK TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. ARE
CURRENTLY SOME- THE CERTIFIED
UNIFIED PROGRAM AGENCY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
AND ENFORCING HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS AND WASTE LAWS. AND
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER HAS
GENERAL AUTHORITY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH. AND
EXPANDED AUTHORITY ONLY AFTER A
COUNTY WIDE EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED. SOME FACILITIES EMIT
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES AND THEY
CONTINUE TO OPERATE PRIME
EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY. I WAS EXCITED BATTERY
RECYCLING FACILITY IN VERNON
CALIFORNIA WHICH CONTINUES
CONTINUOUSLY EXPOSE FAMILIES
AND RESIDENTS. ARE OUT OF OURS
AND THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
TO DANGEROUS LEVELS OF TOXIC
LEAD THE DELAY TO SHUT THIS
FACILITY DOWN LED TO EMISSIONS
FROM THE PLANT CONTAINING
CONTAMINATING MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
ACROSS BOYLE HEIGHTS IN EAST
LOS ANGELES AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES. EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
WILL ENABLE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO DIRECT A FACILITY OR A
PORTION OF A FACILITY TO
TEMPORARILY DISCONTINUE
OPERATIONS THAT EXPOSED OUR
COMMUNITIES THE HARMFUL TOXIC
MATERIALS THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION ON THE MEASURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THING MAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE. I
BACKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD HI
COME BY ADAM HI PROTESTING I
DALLY. GOD HI TORONTO HI
EXAMINED EYE LASER. HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. I WAS SO HI HER TADO
I JONES. NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MON HI
WIRE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN
I NELSON NO A SHOW BOTH. PAM. I
WENT INTO YOU KNOW HI RALPH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
I Y. CASKEY I WINNER I WILL HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORCHES HIS TALLY NO. MELINDA'S
BUT SHOW VOGUE. I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY FIVE. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FIVE. SENATOR PAN. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE- HE IS PREPARED-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS HOLD ON
HERE- SENATOR PENN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. YES I HAVE TO GET ON.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
CENTERS PLEASE PRESENT EIGHTY
SIX FIFTEEN MY SUMMER RODRIGUEZ
WHICH WOULD GRANT MEDICAL
RESINS AND INTERNS EMPLOYED BY
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RIGHT
TO DUE PROCESS BEFORE AN
IMPARTIAL DECISION MAKER
REGARDING ISSUES RELATED
TERMINATION POINT OR DISCIPLINE
FOR MATTERS ARE NOT ACADEMIC OR
CLINICAL. NOW I WILL POINT OUT
THAT I HAVE A PREVIOUS BEFORE I
CAME TO LEGISLATORS ACTUALLY
RESIDENCY DIRECTOR AND
CERTAINLY HERE HERE DURING COLD
AND WE HAVE RECOGNIZED THERE
BEEN TIMES WHEN. MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND NURSES AND
OTHER HEALTH PROFESSIONALS HAVE
SOMETIMES HAD TO SPEAK OUT
ABOUT POLITICAL ISSUES OR
THINGS RELATED TO- TO THE CARE
OF PATIENTS THAT HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY BEEN DISCIPLINED.
OR BEEN TOLD THAT THE THEY NEED
TO BE SILENT WHEN THEY'RE
SPEAKING OUT FOR THEIR
PATIENTS. WE NEED TO BE SURE
OUR RESIDENTS ARE ABLE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AS WELL SO THAT
RESIDENTS ADDITIONS TO OUR
PHYSICIANS BUT THERE ARE. THERE
ARE TRAINEES BUT THEY WILL NOT
BE DISCIPLINED INAPPROPRIATELY
FOR THINGS WHEN THEY'RE
SPEAKING OUT ARE NOT RELATED TO
OUR OWN FARMERS BUT TO PATIENTS.
AGAIN MEDICAL RESIDENTS ARE
PHYSICIANS THAT ARE TREES THAT
ARE. IN HOSPITALS- SPENDING PER
DARE TO LEARNING HOW TO- TAKE
CARE PATIENTS BUT THEY NEED TO
ALSO ADVOCATE FOR EXAMPLE THEY
SPEAK OUT AND SAY WE NEED MORE.
PP FOR OURSELVES TO KEEP OUR
PATIENTS SAFE THEY SHOULD NOT
BE DISCIPLINED FOR THAT.
VIRTUALLY ALL OTHER EMPLOYEES
AT THE MERCY CALIFORNIAN JOY
IMPARTIAL DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
AND THERE'S NO REASON. TO DENY
MEDICAL RESIDENTS THE SAME
EQUAL TREATMENT. EIGHTY SIX
FIFTEEN IS A REINTRODUCTION OF
EIGHTY TO TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
WHICH WAS VETOED LAST YEAR.
HOWEVER THE VETO MESSAGE
DIRECTED THE SPONSORED
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE WORK ON
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL BEFORE
YOU REFLECTS THAT AGREEMENT.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY S.
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY ROOM PHYSICIANS.
ESPECIALLY ASPIRIN I VOTE.
SENATOR DRAWS OF. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OUR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING MAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I HATE.
BACKER HI FORGES I BRADFORD I
COME BY IT ALL HI CORTESE I
DALLY NO DOG. I AWESOME I
EXAMINED EYE LASER. GONZALEZ
FIVE GROVE. NO HERTZBERG. WHAT
IS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
LIVE MON. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A TRUCK
BROKE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO I
ROCKED I. RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG I WAKE OUT SKI I
WINNER. I WILL NO PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. BATES NO
GLAZER. HERTZBERG MELINDA'S NO
NIELSEN NO. STERN. FIVE THIRTY
NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ONTO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY NINE
SENATOR ROTH IS PREPARED ADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS CENTER ROCKED
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THIS IS THE SUNSET
BILL FOR THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING IT EXTENDS
THE BOARD AND COVER NINETEEN
PROVISIONS BY ONE YEAR CARS THE
BORDER REGISTERED NURSING
OPPOSED THE AVAILABILITY OF ITS
TEMPORARY LICENSE. ON ITS
WEBSITE AND MAKES VARIOUS
TECHNICAL CHANGES RESPECTFULLY
AS FEAR OF A- FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SAYING NO OBJECTION EYES THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. I'M JUST GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTEEN.
SENATOR REID TUSKEGEE HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AND I
BROUGHT RELATIVE TO INDIA'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY CENTER RECORDS
GIVE THE FLOOR'S YOURS MADAM
PRESIDENT WITH A POPULATION OF
MORE THAN ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION PEOPLE THE REPUBLIC OF
INDIA IS THE WORLD'S LARGEST
DEMOCRACY AND SHARES A
COMMITMENT TO THE BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
FREEDOM OPPORTUNITY AND JUSTICE
THIS- ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO RECOGNIZE THE
POSITIVE RELATIONS AND
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN INDIA
UNITED STATES AND ITS PEOPLE.
IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT A
C. R. NINETY SEVEN IN HONOR OF
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE DAY AND
CELEBRATE THE VAST
CONTRIBUTIONS- MADE BY INDIAN
AMERICANS. OF OUR GREAT STATE
BACK URGENT I'VE- FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE AND I
THANK YOU I ALSO RISE AS A
PROUD PRINCIPLE CALL A CO
AUTHOR OF H. U. R. NINETY SEVEN
THE GREAT THIRTY SECOND SENATE
DISTRICT IS HOME TO ONE OF THE
LARGEST INDIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE INDIAN
AMERICANS ARE UNDENIABLE I
ASKED YOU TO JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING THEIR HERITAGE
CULTURE AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
MAKE IN OUR STATE AS GREAT AS
IT IS TODAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. HUNTER PENCE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- CENTERS ARE TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
C. R. NINETY SEVEN- AS CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- CERTAINLY
WANT TO BE SURE WE RECOGNIZE
THE INDEPENDENCE DAY OF THE
WORLD WANTS. TO WORK THE
WORLD'S LARGEST DEMOCRACIES AS-
WE HEAR ALSO CELEBRATE
DEMOCRACY IN OUR COUNTRY. AND
AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE. SENATOR NELSON. MADAM
PRESIDENT LATER GEM OF THE
SENATE. AS A REPRESENTATIVE FOR
WHAT WE CALL THE PUNJAB OF
AMERICA WHICH IS NORTH OF HERE
AROUND THE CITY AREA WHERE SO
MANY. OF THE INDIAN POPULATION
SETTLED AFTER THE A
PARTITIONING AND EIGHT AT
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT. AND AS
ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF THE POP
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION WHICH DOES INCLUDE.
THE END OF COMMUNITY AS PART OF
OUR MEMBERSHIP THAN BY MIGHT
NOTE THAT ORGANIZATIONS
CELEBRATING ITS TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY THIS WEEK. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE HAS A
PART OF A BIGGER CULTURAL
FELLOWSHIP I TRAVELED THROUGH
INDIA. WHEN I BROUGHT HOME FROM
WORK A PROFOUND OBSERVATION. AS
WE TRAVELED THROUGH INDIA TO
THE MOST IMPOVERISHED VILLAGES
TO THE FASTEST OF THE HOTELS.
AND WE EVEN MET WITH PRIME
MINISTER GANDHI FOR ONE HOUR IN
HER HOME THIRTY SIX. I WAS
SURPRISED AT SOME OF THE
REMARKS OF THE CITIZENS. OF
THAT WONDERFUL COUNTRY. THEY
WEREN'T SO CONCERNED WITH
POVERTY OR THEIR PLIGHT. BUT
THE CASH SYSTEM THEY WERE
CONCERNED THAT AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME PRIME MINISTER
GANDHI HAD WHAT SHE CALLED HER
EMERGENCY POWERS HAD IMPOSED
THAT WAS. ONE OF THE PRODUCTS
OF THAT WAS THERE WERE NO VOTES.
THERE WERE NO ELECTIONS. AND
THOSE PEOPLE OF INDIA
COMPLAINED BITTERLY ABOUT NOT
HAVING THAT OPPORTUNITY. I WAS
STRUCK THEN COMING BACK HERE TO
AMERICA. SEE HOW MANY OF OUR
OWN AMERICANS. DON'T SEEM TO
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT. THEY
DON'T SHOW UP AND GREAT FOR
ALLERGIES. I THINK YOU LEARN
FROM OTHER CULTURES. IN
PARTICULAR YOU OF INTEREST TO
ME IT WAS IN A PROFOUND
STATEMENT TO A FARMER IN THE
PANJAB. WITH CALIFORNIA TECH
FARMERS WE CAME IN WE SAW IN
THE PUNJAB MOST EVERYTHING
BEING PULLED THE FARM EQUIPMENT
BY BULLOCKS. VERY LABOR INTENSE.
SO SOME OF OUR FELLOWSHIP THAT
GEE WHY DON'T YOU JUST BUY BIG
TRACTORS IN LAND PLANES DISKS
AND- ONE OF THE FARMER SAID
SOMETHING VERY PROFOUND TO ME.
WHAT WOULD WE DO WITH THE
PEOPLE. THE PEOPLE WHO WORK THE
LAND. AMANDA. THAT COUNTRY HAS
A LONG AND DISTINGUISHED
HISTORY. VERY HAPPY TO RISE UP
HERE YET AGAIN TODAY. TO
RECOGNIZE THE NATION OF INDIA.
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AC OR NINETY SEVEN AND I'M
IT'S RECOGNIZING INDIANS IN
INDIA'S ENERGY INDEPENDENCE DAY
AND CELEBRATING THEIR
INDEPENDENCE FROM GREAT BRITAIN
WHICH TOOK PLACE ON AUGUST
FIFTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY SIX
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO ONE OF
THE LARGEST POPULATIONS OF M.
ASIAN INDIANS IN THE UNITED
STATES IN MY DISTRICT IS
COMPLIANT COMPRISED OF A LARGE
SEGMENT OF THAT COMMUNITY- MY
COMMUNITY IT WHICH I THINK
THEY'RE WATCHING TODAY THEY
CALL ME PATACA WHICH MEANS
FIRECRACKER. IN AND SO THEY
LOVE THAT TITLE FOR ME AND WHEN
I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
THESE A PRINT JOB EVENTS IN
TELUGU EVENTS MY FAVORITE FOOD
IS DEFINITELY NOT IN PIONEER.
PROBABLY STAND WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN RECOGNIZING THE
SACRIFICES OF THE CITY'S AT
CITIZENS OF INDIA IN DO OR DIE
FOR THEIR FREEDOM. WE HAVE
GREATLY BENEFITED FROM THOSE
WHO'VE MOVED HERE INTO OUR
STATE SHARING THE CULTURE
CULINARY EXPERIENCES AND THEIR
WORK ETHIC AND FAMILY VALUES.
YES MOST OF THESE- PUNJAB ARE
TELUGU INDIANS ARE A LOT OF
THEM ARE IN THE MEDICAL
FACILITY- FIELD. FARMING BUT
THEY ALL HAVE AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT AND SO
THAT'S GREATLY BENEFICIAL TO
OUR STATE. I CAN TELL YOU THAT%
FOR INDIANS EVERYWHERE
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS A REMINDER
TO PAY HOMMAGE TO THE FREEDOM
FIGHTERS WHO FOUGHT HARD. FOR
THEIR COUNTRYMEN'S FREEDOM FROM
GREAT BRITAIN FREEDOM FARMERS
PARTNERED SKEWS ME FREEDOM
FIGHTERS INCLUDE GANDHI. BACK
AT SINI INSTRUCTIVE HELPED
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM FOR ALL
INDIANS AND SO I ASK
RESPECTFULLY FOR A. C. R. A
NINETY SEVEN AND I VOTE. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE CENTER RIGHT BECAUSE CAN
YOU MAKE INCLUDE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES WHO- HAD THEIR INPUT
INTO THE DISCUSSION THIS IS ONE
OF THREE. NATIONAL HOLIDAYS
INDEPENDENCE DAY THAT
CELEBRATES- IN INDIA AND IT
HONORS THE INDIANS EMBRACE OF
DEMOCRACY TOLERANCE AND THE
RULE OF LAW AND I WOULD URGE AN
IPHONE. MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SAYING NINE FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER. FILE
NUMBER TWO SIXTY FILE NUMBER
TWO SIXTY SENATOR EARLY MORNING
ARE YOU PREPARED SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER YOUTH
SENATOR LEE MOWING THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU I RACE TODAY TO
PRESENT AT SIX FORTY WHICH
HELPS DRAW DOWN ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE THE FEDERAL
FOSTERING CONNECTIONS TO
SUCCESS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. GAVE STATES THE OPTION
OF EXTENDING FOSTER CARE TO AGE
OF TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA DOT
DID THIS OPTION FOR THE PASSAGE
OF AB TWELVE IN TWENTY TEN TO
ALLOW FOSTER YOUTH AGES
EIGHTEEN TO REMAIN IN CARE
WITHOUT A NEW FOSTER CARE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION UPON
ENACTMENT AB TWELVE INCLUDED A
CAP ON COUNTY FISCAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE COST OF
THE PROGRAM AND REQUIRES THE
STATE TO FUND NON FEDERAL
SHARE. OF THIS THE NON FEDERAL
SHARE OF THE EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM COSTS THAT EXCEED
THE CAP STATES ARE PERMITTED TO
RE DETERMINE FEDERAL
ELIGIBILITY AT THE TIME THE
FOSTER YOUTH ENTERS THE AB
TWELVE PROGRAM PURSUANT TO
FEDERAL POLICY HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA'S PRO PROGRAM IS NOT
CURRENTLY DESIGNED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS POLICY EIGHTY
SIX FORTY CORRECTS THAT
OVERSIGHT AND ENABLES COUNTIES
TO RE DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY AT
THE TIME A YOUTH ENTERS
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE WITHOUT
ANY DISRUPTION TO THEIR
SERVICES. OR SUPPORTING FUNDING
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION
DEBATE SAYING MAN MEMBERS THIS
IS A THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SAYING NINE FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SIXTY ONE
SENATOR ALAN HE IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND ACTUALLY
NEED TO PUBLIC RESOURCES.
SENATOR ALAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
FIGURE OUT A PRESENT THIS IS
THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE OMNIBUS BILL. THE MIX
NON CONTROVERSIAL TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES THE STATUTES
AFFECTING CAL FIRE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY AND CAL RECYCLE.
OBVIOUSLY IS- BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECT
FASHIONABLE. MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SAYING MAN. MEMBERS THIS IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THAT. SAYING NINE ICE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
SIXTY TWO SENATOR MAN IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES SENATOR
MEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CALLING
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN ALLOWS
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO CAPTURE
IMAGES OF VEHICLES VIOLATING
PARKING PROHIBITIONS IN TRANSIT
ONLY LANES. AND THOSE BLOCKING
BUS STOPS BUS ONLY LANE
VIOLATIONS AND PARKED VEHICLES-FORCE TRANSIT OPERATORS TO
MANEUVER AROUND CONGESTED LANES
AND MAKE DROP OFFS FURTHER FROM
THE CURVE IS BECAUSE SIR
SERVICE DELAYS AND POST SAFETY
ISSUES TO WRITERS WHO NEED
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE INCLUDING
THE ELDERLY AND DISABLED.
CAMERON FORSMAN PROGRAMS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND ELSEWHERE HAVE
SHOWN GREAT SUCCESS IN REDUCING
VIOLATIONS IN IMPROVING TOP
TRAVEL TIMES. PROGRAMS HAVE
REPORTED CLOSE 220% IMPROVEMENT
IN ON TIME PERFORMANCE AND IT'S
SEEN A REDUCTION IN REPEAT
VIOLATORS. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN PROVIDES TRANSIT
AGENCIES WITH A COST EFFECTIVE
TOOL TO ENSURE RAPID AND SAFE
BUS SERVICES. ESPECIALLY FOR
BUSY STREETS OR IN PERSON
PARKING ENFORCEMENT IS NOT
REALISTIC. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN ALSO CONTAINS
GUARDRAILS FOR CONSUMER AND
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. IT WILL
IMPROVE OUR TRANSIT PUBLIC
TRANSIT TIME WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO REDUCE.
OUR GREENHOUSE EMISSIONS HI AND
IT WILL SERVE THE INTERESTS OF
THE COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I BASE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD I HAVE A
ARE YOU PROTESTING I DALLY NO
DOG FIVE TORONTO. EGGMAN I
LASER HI CONSOLIDATE MY GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON HI
THERE I MELINDA'S. NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH I CAN. HI FORTUNE TINO I.
ROSS I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
STERN. NUMBER FIVE BY CAL SKI.
WINNER HI WELL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. THEY'RE ALSO.
SKINNER STERN WHITE HOUSE GATE
I THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS RATED
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
FIFTY NINE SENATOR MINUTES
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRI NORRIS
AN ACT RELATING TO MARINE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FIVE EIGHTY SIXTY
THREE WOULD ADD THE WORDS
RSTORATION AND MONITORING THE
LIST OF PERMITTED ACTIVITIES
AND MARINE CONSERVATION AREAS
THIS IS AN UNOBJECTIONABLE BILL
THAT'S RECEIVE NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION BUT WHICH WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR HELPING OUR
COASTAL PRESERVATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS. C.
NINE FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE BACK. TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS AND TAKE UP ITEM FOR
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE
SENATOR ATKINS IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AN ACT RELATING TO
COASTAL RESOURCES BETTER PRO
TEM THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATE BILL
ONE IS BACK BEFORE US TODAY ON
CONCURRENCE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS CLARIFIED THE REVIEW
SPECTOR ROLES OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL. AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY IN
IMPLEMENTING AD OVERSEEING THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO SEA LEVEL
RISE. WE CERTAINLY HAVE ALL
EXPERIENCED THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE FROM
DISASTERS LIKE MASSIVE
WILDFIRES WERE WE'VE LOST
HUNDREDS OF LIVES. AND PROPERTY
DESTROYED AND SUFFERED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER COST TO
LONG PERIODS OF SEVERE DROUGHT.
WHICH IS CERTAINLY AFFECTED THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO GROW FOOD AS
WELL. IN FACT WE'RE SEEING THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE RIGHT NOW ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES DUE TO HURRICANE
IDA. IN LOUISIANA NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY. CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ALSO ACUTELY AFFECTING
CALIFORNIA'S COAST IN MORE
SUBTLE IN DAMAGING WAYS THROUGH
SEA LEVEL RISE. STATE
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ONLY IN THE
VERY EARLY STAGES OF PLANNING
FOR AND ANTICIPATING SEA LEVEL
RISE. THE LONGER WE WAIT THE
MORE COSTLY THE DAMAGE WILL BE.
THIS BILL IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS C. LEVEL RISE I ASK FOR
YOUR I. THOUGHT. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. VERY MUCH BUT
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE. TO
BOTH SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
INDICATED EARLY VOTING FOR. BUT
ALSO TO PUT IN CONTEXT HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS. AS WE SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE EAST
COAST TODAY OR YESTERDAY IN NEW
YORK. WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING
LOUISIANA OTHER JOINING STATES.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING ACROSS
THIS GLOBE EVERY DAY- THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE ARE
EXTRAORDINARY AND- WE LOOK AT
SOME OF THE ISSUES RELATED TO
AIR QUALITY IN THE LIKE AND YET
WHEN YOU READ THE STUDIES ABOUT
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING WITH THE
WILDFIRES. IN THE IMPACT THAT
THOSE WILDFIRES ARE HAVING NOT
JUST HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THE QUALITY
AND OTHER ADVERSE.
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS IT'S
CRITICAL AND SO WE LOOK AT THE
PART NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT WE
FACE IN THE CLIMATE CHANGE
PUBLIC POLICY APPROACH THAT WE
TAKE. THAT ALL OF THE VARIOUS
ISSUES. IT IS OFTEN THINGS LIKE
SEA LEVEL RISE THEY DON'T. THAT
THE PUBLIC ATTENTION BUT IN MY
JUDGMENT AND MY EXPERIENCE OVER
MANY DECADES TRAVELING AROUND
THIS GLOBE THIS IS ONE OF THE
GREAT CHALLENGES WE FACE ALONG
WITH WILDFIRES THAT THE SENATE.
HAS TAKEN PRETTY X.
EXTRAORDINARIA TIVITY EFFORTS
WITH RESPECT TO BUDGET REQUESTS
AND OTHER PUBLIC POLICY
ENDEAVORS AND I JUST WANT TO
GIVE THE HOTEL. IN THE OTHER CO
AUTHORS A GREAT DEAL OF CREDIT.
FOR THEIR BIG PICTURE VISION
AND UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS WE DEAL IN ADDRESS
TODAY AS WE SEEK TO PASS AND I
SUPPORT SP ONE. CENTER WHERE
CASCADING. EFFECT THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT HI TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE WIN SEVEN-
COMMITTEE TWO OF THE BUDGET WAS
WORKING ON THE RESOURCES THE
CLIMATE INITIATIVE WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN MAKING ARGUMENTS.
INCREASE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE FROM ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION TO THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION AND WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF THE- DISCUSSIONS RIGHT NOW
WITH THE BUDGET OF WHAT TO DO
BUT THE SENATE PROPOSAL. SET
ASIDE ONE POINT ONE BILLION IS
THE INITIAL DOWN PAYMENT TO DO
THE WORK THAT'S OUTLINED HERE
IN SP ONE WE KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
WHO REPRESENTS NAPA HAS A BIG
PROJECT THERE WOULD. HIGHWAY
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
TRANSFORM THE WHOLE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AND ALLOW FOR A
CAUSEWAY- TO BE CONSTRUCTED IN
TWO FOR WOMEN WE HAVE STORM
SURGES LIKE WE SAW DOWN IN
LOUISIANA WE HAVE. EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS THAT THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT IS GOING TO RESPOND
SO THERE'S PROJECTS IN MY
DISTRICT AND PROJECTS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE THAT ARE LOOKING
TO BE FUNDED AND THIS SETS THE
FRAMEWORK. IN LEGISLATION AND
HOPEFULLY. WITH THE GOVERNOR
SAYS. WHAT IN OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE ASSEMBLY COOPERATION ON AS
WE CAN ROUTE THE LAST. DETAILS
OF THE BUDGET THAT WILL GET.
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS TO DO
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT'S-
ANTICIPATED SP ONE NIGHT URGING
A VOTE. SENATOR EDMUND. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE YOU KNOW I REPRESENT-
PART CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WE SIT
ON THE CALIFORNIA DELTA- AND
THEN THE LONGER THE LARGEST
FRESHWATER ESTUARY IN IN THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE AND IF THE
SEA LEVEL KEEPS RISING AT THE
LEVEL IS RISING RIGHT NOW I AM
NOT CO SIDE BUT WE WILL BE AT
SOME POINT AND I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE INCREDIBLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. MY
SPOUSE'S MORNING AS PEOPLE READ
THEIR NEWS FEED WHEN IT COMES
UP IT'S LIKE BUILDING IN SAN
FRANCISCO JUST TILTED TWENTY
TWO INCHES THAT'S BECAUSE THIS
DOES THE LEVELS RISING AND OUR
GROUND IS SHIFTING MEMBERS
AGAIN I REPRESENT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO MAINTAIN
REPRESENTING CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
YOU DO NOT WANT TO REPRESENT%
THE COAST AND I STRONGLY URGE.
AND I ON SB ONE. AND SPEAKING
OF THE COAST SENATOR LARRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT- WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I DID ONE OF THE FIRST
BILLS ON SEA LEVEL RISE THAT
EVER BEEN DONE IN THE
LEGISLATURE I GOT RIGHT TO THIS
BODY. AND COULDN'T MOVE THE
BILL I WANTED TO INCORPORATE
INTO GENERAL PLANS THAT PEOPLE
WERE TAKEN TO ACCOUNT C. LEVEL
RISE IN HALF THE STAKE HOLDER
SAID WE DON'T WANT THIS BILL
UNLESS YOU GIVE US A REAL
BENCHMARK AND THE OTHER HALF OF
THE STAKEHOLDER SAID- YOU GIVE
US A MATCH MARK WERE AGAINST
THE BILL I COULD NOT BRIDGE
THAT AND THEN LO AND BEHOLD. A
COUPLE OF YEARS LATER I'M
APPOINTED NATURAL RESOURCES
SECRETARY AND I AM IN CHARGE OF
THE SCIENCE THAT ESTABLISHES
THE BENCHMARK AND AS WE IN
TWENTY ELEVEN ON THE SAME DAY
AS THE JAPANESE TSUNAMI.
ADOPTED THE SCIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA IT BASICALLY SAID
THAT WE WOULD BE SOMEWHERE IN
TWENTY FIFTY THAT WOULD BE
EIGHT INCHES OR SOMETHING SEA
LEVEL RISE BUT THAT WAS THE
MEDIAN IF WE REALLY COULDN'T ON
ARE LOWERING EMISSIONSSHOULD
BE LESS IF WE REALLY BAD WOULD
BE HIGHER THAN THE NUMBER OF
FEET. AT TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AND
SO THE THING I ASKED THE
SCIENTISTS AT THE TIME AS
PEOPLE WERE SKEPTICAL ABOUT
LOOKING FOR WORK LET'S LOOK
BACKWARD AND THEY SAID SEVEN
INCHES IN OUR AREA THE CITY HAS
RISEN SINCE THE INDUSTRIAL
RUSSELL REVOLUTION. AND SO NOW
WE KEEP MOVING AHEAD WITH
DIFFERENT THINGS AND WORKED ON
THE SCIENCE WE SEEM TO KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN AND THIS BILL
IS THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP
BECAUSE IT BRINGS PEOPLE AROUND
ALL OVER THE STATE TO ACTUALLY
PLAN TO ACTUALLY DECIDE HOW
WERE WE GOING TO BRIDGE IT SO
IF YOU LOOK AT SENATOR DODD'S
DISTRICT ON THE HIGHWAY THIRTY
SEVEN OR IN THAT AREA. IT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO DO IF YOU
LOOK AT SENATOR AIKMAN'S.
DISTRICT A ONE- FORT. ARISE
SINCE LEVEL. WOULD CHANGE THE
TWO FIVE HUNDRED YEARS. TO A
TEN YEAR FLOOD IN THE WESTERN
DELTA. SO THESE ARE THINGS WE
CAN'T RUN AWAY FROM AND THIS
BILL HELPS US IN A WAY THAT
THAT WE CAN DO OUR BEST TO BE
READY SO I SALUTE THE AUTHORS
AND I CALL FOR AN I. PHONE.
SENATOR CAN. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CENTERS I TOO I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SP ONE AND
I TO LIKE MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
STOCKTON- REPRESENTS NOT A
COASTAL REGION BUT SOMETHING A
LITTLE MORE INLAND FACT FREE
RIGHT HERE AND AS WE SIT HERE
DEBATING THIS BILL- PERHAPS WE
OUGHT TO GIVE SOME THOUGHT TO
EXACTLY HOW MANY FEET WE ARE
ABOVE SEA LEVEL. AS WE SIT HERE
RIGHT NOW. AND THAT'S WHAT SEA
LEVEL RISE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SEA LEVEL RISE WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT AND I THINK IT'S
MENTIONED BY TO MY COLLEAGUES
BEFORE. YOU KNOW ONE FOOT RISE
IN SEA LEVEL CERTAINLY IS GOING
TO BE A CHALLENGE FOR THE COAST
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY CHALLENGE FOR
US RIGHT HERE. YOU KNOW THE
TERMS OF FLOOD RISK SO WE
USUALLY WORRY ABOUT. FLOODS
COMING FROM THE FOOTHILLS
GREAT. UNSERE AS COMING DOWN
WITH A PINEAPPLE EXPRESS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WELL DON'T
FORGET WATER TO BACK UP THE
OTHER WAY. A TEN FOOT RISE I
THINK WOULD BASICALLY MAKE
BOTH. MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
STOCKTON AND I REPRESENTING A
FAIRLY QUIET X. DISTRICT. SO
YES SALTWATER AQUATIC DISTRICT
AND- SO. WE NEED TO DEFINITELY
ADDRESS THIS EFFECT NOT JUST R.
TWO DISTRICTS I THINK MANY
OTHER DISTRICTS OF BOTH
SEGMENTS SAM KEENE VALLEY
START. ARE GONNA BE UNDER
WATER. SO WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS- THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD. I APPRECIATE A
LOT FOCUSES ON THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND THINGS ON THE
COAST BUT THIS IS ALSO IN
INLAND CALIFORNIA PROBLEM.
ESPECIALLY. AS WHEN I BUY IT.
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I TO RISE AND
SUPPORTED THANK GOD. THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO WHO IS
WHO CAN VISION DESKSIDE COUPLE
YEARS AGO BUT BECAUSE OF THE
COLD YET. I GOT SIDE TRACKED
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT BEFORE OF MY
DISTRICT SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX BASICALLY HAVE A WHOLE
FRONTAGE. ALONG THE PACIFIC.
COAST AND- HAS SUFFERED SOME
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS- INCLUDING
THE DEATHS OF A- FOR MEMBERS OF
THE FAMILY THREE MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILY DUE TO A CAR. THE
COASTAL BLUFF OF COLLAPSE SO
IT'S MY WHOLE- WITH THE GROUP
THAT COMES TOGETHER THAT ALL.
MITIGATIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES
TO ADDRESS EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF THESE WILL BE ENTERTAINED
AND AT THAT TIME. WE WILL HAVE
THINGS THAT ARE OF SPECIFICALLY
TAILOR MADE FOR TAILOR MADE FOR
EACH OF THE AREAS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN ADDRESSED TODAY- A
SPECIFIC MITIGATION THAT
MATCHES THE- THE NEEDS IN THOSE
PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
THERE'S A WIDE ARRAY. AND I
GUESS THE WIDE ARRAY OF IDEAS.
ON HOW THIS IS TO BE DONE AT
ONE THAT IS TROUBLING WHEN IT'S
THE ONLY ONE TO BE CONSIDERED
AS THE MANAGE RETREATS THAT'S
CONTINUALLY DEBATED. IT HAS
CERTAINLY ABSOLUTE APPLICATION
IN SOME AREAS BUT NOT AT ALL
PHIL I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
INTRODUCTION AND THE SUPPORT.
ACROSS THE MANY OF THE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE SPOKEN
TODAY. AND LOOK FORWARD TO SOME.
GOOD THINGS COMING OUT OF THIS
THANK YOU. SENATOR CAN. I T.
ONE S. THINK ABOUT A PRESIDENT
I TOO WANT TO- OUR- PRO TEM FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD VERY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY IN PLACES
LIKE LONG BEACH WHICH I
REPRESENT- REPORTS HAVE BEEN
TWO HUNDRED FORTY ALMOST
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE NEXT TWO DECADES JUST TO
PROTECT OUR SEA WALLS IN THE
CITY- WE HAVE PLANS IN PLACE I
THINK THIS WOULD HELP THEM
IMPLEMENT MANY OF THOSE PLANS
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROTECTED
ON TOP OF THAT A LOT OF CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS LOCALLY
THAT ARE BEING PLANNED NEAR US
BASES THAT WILL BE ESSENTIALLY
UNDER WATER IN THE NEXT DECADE
NOT EVEN TWO DECADES. SO WE
NEED TO START PRE PLANNING NOW
AND ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ALL
STAKE HOLDERS- AT THE AT THE
HELLMAN I LOVE THAT THIS CALLS
OUT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GROUPS AS WELL AND I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH IT WAS. STRICTLY
S. FERNANDO. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE-
OKAY. SENATOR ALAN WILLIAMS I
ALSO STAND SUPPORT FOR THAT
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY- UNFORTUNATELY STILL
OR THE CLIMATE CHANGE STILL
ARISES IS BECOMING A FACT WE'RE
DOING EVERY WE NEED TO DO MORE
TO STEM THIS THIS TERRIBLE
CATASTROPHIC TRANSFER PLANET-
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE START TO PLAN FOR
ITS INEVITABILITY- AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL HELPS
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
COAST HERE SO I STRONGLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE TO ISSUE ONE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THE SAME MAN MADAM PER
TERM YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT TO MY
COLLEAGUES LET ME JUST SAY
THANK YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION
AND THE SUPPORT AND TO THE CO
AUTHORS AND BASICALLY EVERYONE
THAT HAS COME TOGETHER ON THIS
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE IN
LISTENING TO OUR COLLEAGUE- WHO
IS THE FORMER. NATURAL
RESOURCES SECRETARY AND TO HEAR
HIS EXPERIENCE FROM HIS EARLIER
DAYS IN THE ASSEMBLY WHAT A
DIFFERENCE- A LITTLE MORE THAN
A DECADE MAKES IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE SEE BEFORE US IN THE
SITUATION WE'RE IN ALL IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING COASTAL
COMMUNITIES ARE IN LINE FOR WE
HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
WATERSHEDS AND OFF. GROUND
WATER AND US SO MANY OTHER
THINGS THAT IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE THINKING WOULD
HAVE TO DEAL WITH SEA LEVEL
RISE TO SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
INDICATED BUT I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO HIM- AS THE FORMER
SECRETARY FOR DOING THE WORK
THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE TO BACK
THIS UP AS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND WITH THAT-
I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU AND
ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE THIS
CONCURRENCE BILLS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
FIVE EIGHT FIVE BECKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I BYRON HI
CHRIS HAS HE HI DOLLY. GOD HI
DURACELL FIVE A COMMON HI
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES NO ONE CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LLEVA FIVE THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW A
VOGUE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
I STERN AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBERS. PORCHES
DALLY NO. GROVE MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN STERN. FIVE THIRTY
THREE NOSE TO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GONNA GO
WE'RE GONNA END IN A IN A
MINUTE WE'RE PART WE'RE GOING
TO CALL. WE'RE GONNA LET THE
CALL BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT I
WANT TO TAKE A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AND WISH A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO. SENATOR BEN
WESO. HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
CURRENT
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO LIFT
CALLS ON BILLS SO THIS IS A
GOOD TIME TO BE LISTENING TO
SEE IF YOU MISSED A VOTE. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH A FILE AND
I'M TWENTY FIVE GOVERNORS
APPOINTMENT MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN I. WEST SO I- TADO I CAN
LONGER I MON I MELINDA'S I
NEWMAN I NELSON. I SKINNER I
STERN WEINER I HIGHS THIRTY
NINE TO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN GOVERNORS
APPOINTMENT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WITH SO I HER
TADO I. CAN LONGER. FIVE LET
ALONE I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I
PATROL BOAT I STERN WEINER. HI
FIVE THIRTY NINE ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY SP SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORCHES I GROVE I WEST SO I
HURTADO I. MON I NEWMAN I STERN
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONFERRED
IN FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO SP
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HER TADO HI
THE CHOIR. I STERN. FIVE THREE
NINE NINE ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
PART I ITEM THIRTY FIVE S. P.
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THIRTY FOUR
EXCUSE ME FOR ONE THIRTY FOUR
SP NINETY SEVEN. HER TADO I
TURN. I THIRTY NINE OH ZERO IS
SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE S. B. ONE
OH NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. EGGMAN I HER TADO I
STERN FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FAT ITEM THIRTY
SIX S. P. TWO SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORGES HER TADO. NO MELINDA'S.
STERN. FIVE THIRTY THREE NEWS
FOR THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PART I ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SP THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HURTADO I STERN. FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCLUDED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE SP THREE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HER TADO. I
STERN. FIVE THIRTY NINE OH ZERO
DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FALLON FORTY SP THREE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. HER TADO. STERN AMBERG.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN OF THOSE TEN
DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN FILE I'M FORTY ONE S. P.
THREE SIXTY THREE PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. FAITH FOR
JUST. DALLY GROVE. HER TADO I.
JONES MELINDA'S. NIELSEN STERN
WELK FIVE THIRTY MINS ONE
DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN PART I ITEM FORTY TWO SP
THREE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. HERTZBERG I
HER TADO I STERN. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NEWS TWO DECEMBER MOMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PART I ITEM
FORTY THREE SP THREE NINETY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HER TADO I STERN. I THIRTY NINE
OH ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE I'M FORTY
FIVE AS BEFORE- THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HER
TADO I STERN FIVE THIRTY NEWS
NINE DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PART I ITEM FORTY
SEVEN S. BEFORE NINETY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
HER TADO I STERN. FIVE THREE
NINE NINE ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FIVE AND FORTY EIGHT SP FIVE
HUNDRED PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. BATES NO PORGES. HURT
FOR JEFF NO. HER TADO I. PAN I
STERN WHITE HOUSE GATE HI.
PRICE THIRTY KNOWS NINETY
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS- CONCURRED
IN BY ELEVEN FIFTY SP FIVE FIVE
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN FOR JUST. GLAZER
HER TADO I. CAN LONGER. THE MON.
MELINDA'S STERN. PARDON TINO I
DON'T KNOW. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
NO SIX THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
HER TADO HI STERN FIVE THREE
NINE TWO ZERO DECEMBER MOMENTS
ARE TINKERED AND FALLON FIFTY
FOUR SP SIXTEEN PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. HER TADO NO.
LIMONEIRA I. CONTROL BOTH.
STERN PRICE TWENTY NINE NEWS
NINE THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PART I ITEM
FIFTY FIVE SP NINETEEN PLEASE
CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
HERTZBERG I HER TADO I PAN.
RUBIO I STERN CAN I FIVE THIRTY
NINE ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
FINE FIFTY SEVEN SP FOUR FIFTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I
HURTADO I STERN FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO DECEMBER
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FINAL ITEM FIFTY EIGHT SB SEVEN
TWO TWO PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE NUMBERS. TORONTO
EGGMAN I. GROVE HI HURTADO I
STERN. THEY'RE ALSO I'D- FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLYAMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FUN FIFTY THREE SP
SEVEN ONE FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES PORCHES.
GROVE NO. HER TADO I TRIED BOTH.
STERN WELK. BY BATES NO. FIVE
THIRTY NO SIX THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX SP THREE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE NUMBERS. PORCHES NO
HER TADO. STERN. FIVE FORTY
NINE NEWS NINETY ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS OR CONCURRED IN PART
I ITEM SIXTY FIVE AC R. SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. DALLY GROSS. HER TADO
I JONES. MELINDA'S STERN. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES PILOT I'M SIXTY
NINE EIGHTY THREE NINETY PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE OF MEMBERS. HER
TADO I STERN FIVE THIRTY NINE
NINE ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
ITEM. SEVENTY THREE EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. FATES NO. HER
TADO I STERN FIVE THIRTY NEWS
NINE THE MEASURE ASSES IRELAND.
ONE FORTY TO EIGHTY ONE FIVE
FIVE ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. ATKINS I.
NEWMAN STERN. FIVE TWENTY SIX
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU MEMBERS THOSE ARE ALL
OF OUR BILLS THAT WERE ON CALL
ONE MOMENT.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO OUR JOURNEY IN
MEMORIES. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH SENATOR BATES. FOR NAVY
HOSPITAL MAN MAXTON SO. AND
STAFF SERGEANT DARIAN TAYLOR
HOOVER SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MCGINNIS. THE
TRAGEDY THAT HAPPENED TO OUR
GOOD SERVICEMAN WHO WERE
EVACUATING ALL AMERICANS AND
OUR AFGHAN FRIENDS OTHER
CABOODLE SO I'M WRITING TO
ADJOURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
STAFF SERGEANT DARREN TAYLOR
HOOVER OF THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS STAFF SERGEANT WHO
WERE AT JUST THIRTY ONE WITH
THE OLDEST AMERICAN KILLED IN
THE AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH
TERRORIST ATTACK. IN
AFGHANISTAN HE GREW UP IN UTAH
AND WAS LIVING IN A LISA VIEJO
IN MY DISTRICT ALSO DEPLOYED
FROM CAMP PENDLETON AND MY
DISTRICT BEFORE HE DEPLOYED TO
AFGHANISTAN WHEN NEWS STORY ALL
REPORTED THAT STAFF SERGEANT
HOOVER WAS ELEVEN YEARS OLD
WHEN THE SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH
TERRORIST TERRORIST ATTACKS
HAPPENED HE KNEW EVEN THEN THAT
HE WANTED TO FIGHT BACK. IN
HIGH SCHOOL HE KNEW HE WANTED
TO JOIN THE MARINES HE SERVED
IN THE MARINES FOR ELEVEN YEARS
AND WAS ON HIS THIRD ON HIS
THIRD TOUR IN AFGHANISTAN WHEN
HE WAS KILLED ACCORDING TO THE
MARINES HAD SERVED UNDER HIM
STAFF SERGEANT HOOVER WITH A
LEADER WHO TOOK HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES VERY SERIOUSLY
HE TRAINED OTHER MEN AND WOMEN
AND MADE SURE THEY WERE AS
PREPARED. AS HE WAS TO COMPLETE
THEIR MISSION HIS LEADERSHIP IS
ALREADY DEEPLY MISSED HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS FATHER DARREN
HIS MOTHER KELLY HIS SISTER'S
TORY AN ALLEY AND HIS FIANCEE
NICOLE I OFTEN WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF STAFF SERGEANT HOOVER
AND THE OTHER NATION MOURNS THE
THIRTEEN SERVICE MEMBERS KILLED
IN THE AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH
ATTACK. THE IMPACT IS EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANT IN MY DISTRICT
WHICH IS HOME. TO MARINE CORPS
BASE CAMP PENDLETON. TEN OF THE
THIRTEEN SERVICE MEMBERS
INCLUDING STAFF SERGEANT HOOVER
WERE BASED THERE. SO AFTER WE
ALSO INJURED IN THE MEMORY OF
THE OUT OF STATE MEMBERS WHO
WERE BASED AT CAMP PENDLETON.
AND WE'RE OUR HONORARY
CALIFORNIANS THEIR NAMES ARE
LANCE CORPORAL DAVID ESPINOZA
OF RIO BRAVO TEXAS. LANCE
CORPORAL RYLEE MCCOLLUM OF
JACKSON WYOMING. CORPORAL
DEEGAN PAGE OF OMAHA NEBRASKA.
CORPORAL IN BERTO SANCHEZ OF
LOGANSPORT INDIANA. LANCE
CORPORAL JARED SMITH OF ST
CHARLES MISSOURI. A NAVY
HOSPITAL MAN MAXSON PHOBIA.
LOWS AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THEIR SERVICE WE WILL MISS THEM
TERRIBLY BUT ALWAYS IN OUR
HEARTS AND MINDS UNTIL WE MEET
AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR BREAK PLEASE PLEASE
BRING THEIR NAMES FORWARD SO
THEY MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BUT CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR NIELSEN FOR
MARINE CORPORAL SERGEANT NICOLE
L. G. SENATOR NELSON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I. REQUEST
PERMISSION TO ADJOURN IN HONOR
OF SERGEANT NICOLE HE- NICOLE
HAILED FROM ROSEVILLE. JUST A
SHORT WAYS UP THE ROAD HERE.
SHE WAS LITERALLY ON THE FRONT
LINES. THE OTHER DAY. WHEN SHE
LOST HER LIFE SHE GAVE HER LIFE.
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE GAS AND
AGAIN STAND AND FOR THE PEOPLE
OF THE UNITED STATES. SHOULD
SHORTLY BEFORE THAT I HAD A
PICTURE TAKEN. DURING ONE OF
HER FAVORITE THINGS. HOLDING A
YOUNG AFGHAN CHILD. THERE SHE
WAS STANDING THERE IN HARM'S
WAY. SHE WAS TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT AFGHAN H. THE AMERICANS.
COULD ESCAPE FROM THAT COUNTRY.
AND FOR THE FATE THE MAN WHO
WAS GOING TO THE FOLDER. SHE
GRADUATED FROM LEBANON HIGH
ROSEVILLE AND THEN LISTED IN
THE UNITED STATES MARINES. THE
COMING TO START. SHE MARRIED
HER HUSBAND GERALD. HE ALSO AS
MARIE. AND HE WAS ALSO A HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE. WITH THE COLD.
SHE HAS A FAMILY THAT LOVED HER
AND A COMMUNITY THAT LAUGHTER.
A COUPLE NIGHTS AGO. OVER A
THOUSAND PEOPLE SHOWED UP. IN
ROSEVILLE. TO HONOR HER TO
HONOR HER SERVICE. HER COUNTRY.
AND HER WORLD IN FACT. THIS
PHOTO WAS POSTED SHE AND THE
CHILD IN ONE OF THOSE VIRAL
INCIDENCES. THAT WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER. BUT CERTAINLY WE CAN
NEVER FORGET. HER COURAGE AND
THAT SPLENDID LONELINESS SHE
MUST'VE FELT. STANDING THERE AT
THE FRONT LINES KNOWING HOW AT
RISK SHE WAS. DOING HER DUTY. I
THINK IF ANYTHING STANDS OUT
ABOUT THIS YOUNG WOMAN. TO
DETER DOING. AND THOUGH SHE
HELD ANOTHER WOMAN'S CHILD.
BECAUSE OF DOING HER DUTY SHALL
NEVER HOLD HER OWN CHILD. AND
HER FAMILY WILL ALWAYS GRIEF.
MAY WE HONOR HER. THE SINGING
HER PRAISES. AND- DURING YOUR
HONOR TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE NEXT I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR OCHO VOGUE
FOR MARINE CORPS LANCE
CORPORAL. DYLAN OR MAROA FENDER
GILL BOOK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RICE STREET JOURNAL
MEMORY OF MARINE CORPS LANCE
CORPORAL DYLAN THE ROLLER
MARILLA TRAGICALLY LOST HIS
LIFE AS A RESULT OF THE
HORRIFIC AND SENSELESS ACT
ATTACK IN KABUL AFGHANISTAN HE
WAS TWENTY YEARS OLD AND A
BELOVED MEMBER OF THE SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY THREE FAMILY.
HAVING HIS ROOTS IN RANCHO
CUCAMONGA. HE WAS A GRADUATE OF
THE SERVICES HIGH SCHOOL AND
HAD DREAMS TO GO TO COLLEGE AND
STUDY ENGINEERING. HIS MOM
DESCRIBED HIM AS ONE OF THE
BEST KIDS EVER. KIND. ELEVEN
GIVEN TO EVERY SINGLE PERSON
SOMEONE WHO WOULD GIVE ANYTHING
FOR ANYONE. THERE ARE THERE
WERE PRESENTS THE BEST OF
SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY THREE IN
CALIFORNIA. GIVING TO EVERY
SINGLE PERSON. HE LAID HIS LIFE
ON THE LINE TO DEFEND OUR
FREEDOM AND WAY OF LIFE FOR
THAT WE'RE ETERNALLY GRATEFUL.
HE WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED BY OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT HIS LEGACY OF
BRAVERY AND GENEROSITY WILL
LIVE ON. I ASK THAT YOU WILL
JOIN ME IN PRAYING FOR THE ROLE
OF FAMILY AND ALL THOSE
AFFECTED BY THIS HORRIFIC ACT.
I WILL CLOSE WITH THIS QUOTE BY
JOHN F. KENNEDY. AS WE EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE WE MUST NEVER
FORGET THAT THE HIGHEST
APPRECIATION IS NOT TO UTTER
WORDS BUT TO LIVE BY THEM. MAY
WE HONOR THE LIVES OF THE
THIRTEEN U. S. SERVICEMEMBERS
WHO LAY THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
FOR US. BY LIVING LIVES WORTHY
OF THE SACRIFICE THEY MADE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
TROUBLE PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE'D BE BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE ON THE
CONDITION OF THE FILE MISS
PRESIDENT. EARLIER TODAY. THE
SENATE CONSIDERED IN PAST FILE
THIRTY SIX SP TWO SIXTY SEVEN.
AT THAT TIME THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD ASKED ME A QUESTION
AND I DIDN'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
AND I BELIEVE I HAVE AN ETHICAL
OBLIGATION TO PUT THE ANSWER ON
THE RECORD WHICH I DO SO NOW.
IN THIS B. TWO SIXTY SEVEN THE
JUNE TWENTY FOURTH THE MEMBERS
TAKE IT IN THE OTHER HOUSE
INSERTED NEW LANGUAGE. WHICH
STATES IT APPLIES ONLY TO ONE
PARTNERSHIP FLIP TRANSACTION
WITH RESPECT TO ANY PORTION. OF
ANY ACTIVE SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEM.
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION WAS
YES. IT APPLIES TO ONE SYSTEM
AND I WANTED TO STAND IN MAJOR
AT THE RECORD CORRECTED. TO
SHOW RESPECT TO A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM PRESS. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DILIGENT WORK TODAY-
AND WITH THAT OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
TOMORROW FRIDAY SEPTEMBER THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM HO
TAM THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED WE WILL RECONVENE
TOMORROW FRIDAY AT NINE AM HAVE
A GREAT REST TODAY MEMBERS.